okay so why don't we get started
and
cushions
oh oh
the ones you've guys had in the
community
well you want to check we can check the
office
[Music]
the news is not even a source for
information
one more time
can I buy your opinion
okay no no no okay pencil is fine I'm
easy
I I have
campaign pens I forgot to bring it
okay House Bill 65 requiring Food
Service establishment to salvage food
allergy awareness procedures I think
this is an easy one they did implement
the rules does anybody here from the
Department
yep there you are don't you just tell us
yeah come up and tell us how it's all
going and why we really don't need this
now for the record my name is Abby
Rogers I'm the legislative liaison for
the division of Public Health Services
um I know Colleen Smith is usually here
to talk about food issues but I've got
information on this so I'd be happy to
provide it
um in relation to HP 65 the updated food
rules which are Hep 2300 which would
include the allergen notice to be posted
on menu and menu boards uh which was
effective uh first week of August 2022
so those are in effect food protection
program at the department did an email
blast to all of the establishments
making them aware of the changes
um and we started enforcement on that in
September 1st of 2022. so we also
discussed the rule changes with the
self-inspecting towns and encourage them
to adopt their requirements as well so
that's the update I have on that great
thank you is there anybody have any
questions yeah
I think that's great
um could you tell us what the department
is doing in terms of uh informing the
public that this is or are you doing
anything right I'm sorry uh I think that
we are you know me talking about this
new rule change
um as making restaurant owners aware
certainly um talking to establishments
our inspectors that are involved with
restaurants or making them aware of this
change so as far as further public
Outreach I can get back to you on that
but that's what I'm aware of today what
we're working on thank you for the
question representative Bartlett thanks
very much
um welcome back thank you thank you
certainly seen you before Ms Rogers
um
would you be just refresh our memory
because this was
not this term but
um year before would you refresh our
memories on what the allergens are that
will be shown on the on the menus
sure uh generally I believe that the
allergens that um are involved with this
bill are you know specific to food
allergies so tree nuts
um soy Dairy
um
I believe fish
um and those are the ones that I'm aware
of I certainly can get you a more
comprehensive list but it's generally
all the food allergens that are
recognized by a medical provider would
you be able to send us an email list
just to the committee sure
I just came back from Ireland and I got
to tell you you can go in any Pub any
restaurant any hotel
and every single menu has the
information they just have a little
little asterisk or a little code after
each
menu Choice
um with what the allergens are it was
very simple great no I'd be happy to do
that I didn't that's what we're doing
that's great sure I didn't include
gluten which I'm sure is on that as well
yeah I will get you a comprehensible
yeah
okay
yes generally
um does this include
um
staff
being trained and always having a staff
member in the restaurant at all times to
adhere to the new rules
uh my understanding is that this
certified food protection manager on
staff at all times in restaurants and
less uh which generally are the the
manager that is trained this all the
staff is trained on food allergies
allergens the certified the certified
food protection manager is the person
that sort of implements that within the
restaurant as far as additional training
I think that you know there's certainly
that person does the training and
certainly would communicate the new rule
change to
um the employees of the restaurant and
certainly I would imagine encourage
servers to be aware and you know it's
not in the statute or in law that they
have to ask whether there is a food
allergy but it would encourage customers
to patrons of the restaurant to
contribute that information for the
question just a follow-up
um how can one guarantee that that
professional is going to be in the
restaurant or that everybody's going to
adhere to the policy I really don't see
you can't guarantee that everybody that
goes into the restaurant will be
guaranteed that protection because it
may not be that staff person there they
may not be trained so is theirs
there's maybe a disclosure that a
restaurant can put in the window I guess
they can do whatever they want to do
that there's no staff
you know that can guarantee that can
guarantee that
the employees are abiding by the rules
great thank you for the question I know
that the new rules you know require
require the allergies to be allergens to
be listed
um again we encourage our restaurants to
encourage uh conversation about
allergens um you know I think putting
that on the menu board
um is a reminder for folks to share that
information
um I I don't believe that
um I think it's hard to
um
have 100 compliance with that but
certainly food allergies is you know
it's certainly a very
um serious concern for many people and
we would hope that people uh would do
the best that they can but also
um sort of self-advocate for themselves
if they have an allergen and some of
that some of that is you know something
that could be reminded of for allergists
and providers to to speak to their
patients that have food allergies to
remind them that it's really important
to provide that information when eating
out in a restaurant
these
turn on your mic please
thank you
um I think I'm remembering correctly
um these reminders notices uh
need to be on the menu only not posted
around the building or I know there was
some discussion on one of these bills
that more than just on the menu was
required is the information on the menu
sufficient thank you I believe that it's
up the requirement is on the menu but
also any kind of menu board that the
restaurant should have so if public
facing board where they might list
specials or other restaurant food items
listed
thank you you're welcome
okay
perfect four minutes left thank you very
much
okay and just uh for the committee
members
um
I realized that uh some people were
concerned about are doing our exact
session Wednesday the 26th I did that
because uh Heather was not here and I
was kind of panicked to making sure that
we had an exact session scheduled
um what my expectation is that if we go
through this list and then tomorrow we
find something that we want to come back
and meet again on uh we can do that and
then push off the exact session
otherwise I would I would accelerate if
we get through both of them and find
nothing I would accelerate the exact
session for next week
so yes representative I have a question
so I'm confused so do any of these have
the any of these bills actually had
interim study committees
no but that's what we're doing right now
I'm just I'm yeah right now we're
discussing whether if we want to do a
study I mean that we can take it up you
know uh we can work on it next week but
my question is isn't it the procedure or
at least the custom that there be a
committee have met during the summer and
come back and Report the customers
usually we would meet after September
in this committee now I know some I
don't know as far as I know most
committees weren't allowed to meet in
the summer
chapter studies could meet but uh enter
you weren't allowed to do interim study
committees this summer over the summer
yeah as far as I knew
that it's been changed but that was only
chapter studies so normally we would
meet in the first week of September
there was some requests to delay that
and frankly I went through the list and
I didn't really see anything that was I
thought we were going to really spend a
lot want to spend time on so that's why
I I have this cramp schedule
so I take responsibility for that
thank you
almost almost there
uh so the next one is uh relative to
establishing a Statewide fruit food
truck license
is there anybody here who wants to weigh
in on this one so the way I saw this
issue is that we actually do have a
Statewide license
however if you want to have a truck in a
town or city that has its own license
you would still have to get a separate
license
and since I sensed there was no city or
town who was willing to give that up for
the state one then I think this is one
of those classic bills which is uh has
some great you know great concept to it
for streamlining government but that
unfortunately the the precedent has
already been set that cities and towns
have their own license they're not going
to want to give up that that prerogative
and so at this point
um with it's not you know going forward
with this legislation it's probably
um and there is one food service truck
with a Statewide license already
and it's uh over at the park
uh on the uh on the other side of
Portsmouth
what's the uh
is it Prescott I don't know the name but
there's somebody has a food truck with a
Statewide license yeah there's plenty of
people have a Statewide license in other
words in my town because we don't have
any uh uh the the health department if
you want to call that the person who
charge our health does not have you know
you've been given that Authority by the
Selectmen then they are required to have
a state license so the state license
does exist and a lot of people have them
um and but that at the end of the day
um as representative Hammond points out
it's location it's getting getting that
location and getting that landlord who's
willing to give you the space and and
some cities and towns you know obviously
have other authority uh regulatory
Authority and to to have the state Trump
those cities and towns
would create a a
a legislative nightmare in my in my mind
but I'll open to anybody else's comments
um is there going to be a um a report on
this because I know that there are lsrs
that have been filed regarding uh food
licensing and I think some of them might
be from corks good question so I guess
when we go through this and we're
probably going back to the first one
each one of these one if we all kind of
agree that we're gonna what we're going
to do
um we would I would be entertaining that
motion when we accept the bill for uh
recommend for or against future
legislation
so representative I think I'm going to
put your name down as recommending not
going forward with future legislation so
you'll be prepared to do that when we
exec it yes thank you okay
representative Abramson
yeah I'm just going to say that I like
the idea of the bill
um
from the get-go the reason is I look at
legislation in terms of what it's going
to do in the future I do know uh have
known some food truck operators and I
um where I work we have a difficult time
sometimes getting food trucks and the
food truck operators will sometimes say
well you know you in order to come and
and serve you guys during uh you know
lunch hours or three o'clock to five
o'clock or something like that in order
to move the truck around they have to
get a license from every town and I felt
that if someone got a license it could
be a town license that's recognized
Statewide or it could just be one state
license the one state license made made
more sense to me if you're gonna if
you're gonna essentially have something
that's registered somewhere
um you know as a business it made sense
to also get wherever you know the
business license is usually done through
the or the incorporation is done through
the state it made sense to me to just go
ahead and have it just you know do it
once and allow it because it's a truck
allow it to move from town to town
wherever the demand is now obviously I
represent uh the southern Seacoast so
the demand during the summer is very
different from the demand in the winter
so perhaps some trucks would want to
come out and serve some of the demand
you know out along Route 1 or uh that
area during the summer time and might
want to move around that's kind of one
of the benefits of the truck but I think
that uh I think having a Statewide
license made sense as a concept
right but you understand that the
problem is we have a state line license
and and pretty much all the cities and
towns probably required to get that
license anyways so that's a license
everybody has the intent of the
legislation was that it would Trump
any City or Town's own regulations
related to food trucks by saying is as
long as they had that state license they
were not required to get that Community
license do you agree with that I I
understand what you're saying but I
would liken it to say State firearms
license versus a federal firearms
license the federal firearms license
it's a much higher standard to get
and it make it makes sense I have
private investigators and people who
work on the border they get a federal
firearms license and even federal
employees the federal is a higher much
higher standard admittedly to get that
once you have that it's a higher
standard than any state would ever have
for a concealed weapons permit so it
it's something that uh current and
former uh
um
Federal enforcement uh have everywhere
and that the gun dealers have
um it it makes sense to me even if it's
a higher standard for a state license
that it's a higher standard than any
particular town has once you go through
the process a food truck should be
allowed to move throughout the state
um and looking at it from the consumer
standpoint it it it makes sense that
once the higher standard is met why not
let the truck do what a food truck does
which is drive to where the demand is at
that particular time of year that
particular time of day not
okay well by the way I understand you're
saying this okay you use that example
that would mean that there would be no
state
gun laws
because there's a federal gun law there
would be no state law that's what this
bill does what this bill does says is
that if the city in town has a code
enforcer who goes around to every
restaurant and makes sure that those
those restaurants are in compliance with
all the food and whatever the
requirements
that this legislation was intent was to
say they did not have any right to
regulate
a food truck that because the state had
a regulation they
had no Authority
do you agree with that
do I do I agree with something
philosophically or am I saying no that's
what the bill did what I'm saying so we
without we held the bill because there
are issues that are opened up that might
be worked on later
right so the code enforcement officer
comes around and makes sure among other
things that you already have a license
if somebody has a town license or a
state license they already have a food
license
I don't see
from for that particular interaction I
don't see a reason why that code
enforcement officer they checked the
hygiene they've made sure that you're
everyone's tested as a food handler's
permit and so forth and you have a
license if it's a town license or you or
a state license in in my opinion either
way I I don't believe that the code
enforcement officer should be shutting
down a food truck or telling them you
have to go to this other town because
you're safe to serve in Hampton but
you're not yet safe to serve in Seabrook
if you already have a state license then
you already have you've already gone
through the process why make someone go
through the process again for 239
different people because that city or
town had regulations that were not
included in the Statewide one
foreign
well you and I see it differently we're
different members and I I presume that
we're not going to be voting the same
way just as we haven't been voting the
same way very often uh on the floor okay
any more discussion on
okay uh just to go back to 65 who would
like to make the motion of not
recommended for future legislation on
the allergy awareness procedure Billy
you want to do that one also okay great
foreign
so if we get through all these bills
today with the consensus
then we could move the exact session up
to next week
right now it's scheduled for the 26th
because I didn't want I want to leave
the opportunity that if we had something
where we're kind of divided on that we
could
we could work on it
okay
uh I don't see
episode well it might not be here I know
I talked to him
um HB 1589 prohibiting the sale of
products containing intentionally added
pfas
um I did talk to representative Boyle
the sponsor and he agrees this is this
issue is way bigger than than he he or
anybody has imagined and I assume you
all got emails you know from
different lobbyist groups you know
interested on it I can tell my own
personal story and that is that um
My Family Foundation we have a grantee
who's uh was very proud of uh
legislation to happen in the state of
Washington I didn't actually find out
exactly what they did but
um so now you know I'm intrigued to
learn more about this and about pfas and
so wherever iOS I talked about it so two
weeks ago I was at a wedding in in
Killington Vermont
um and which I was very excited to do
because I'm I'm on the committee too if
Killington does separate from the union
from Vermont and I'm on the designated
person because I was chair of
legislative administration at the time
that uh that would be part of the
welcoming committee to that they could
come to me we would take him on this is
a community in New Hampshire
um but notwithstanding that so when I
was talking to the the hotel I was
staying at he's he mentioned that they
had a pfas problem in Killington
and I called Killington then repeat that
but ski wax I mean what could what could
be the problem in there and I looked it
up and there was two towns I mean two
schools two schools
and uh another condo development
and so when I talked to representative
Boyle about it and I said the only thing
I could figure out probably happened was
and they have not actually determined
exactly where the pfas came from but
that the only thing I think going to
happen is from base what little
knowledge I now have on pfas it was
probably the cleaning products that they
were using in the schools
and that every time they would take they
would dump the bucket out into the into
the sinks and oh there you are okay and
then uh and they would dump them out and
I think that that just somehow got into
their septic you know the septic from
their septic it got into their water
system and polluted their water and uh
but even Vermont having having that
problem they're having trouble getting
struggling to enforce this uh regulation
on those school districts to change
their water so at this point in time
those two schools they give out bottled
water you cannot drink the water in the
in the school but
so uh clearly you know pfas is a major
federal issue that's got to be resolved
at some point uh the EPA I guess when
the governor of California vetoed the
bill there he did mention that that the
EPA is working on trying to regulate it
and trying to figure out get her arms
around from whether it's 6 000 or 12
000 you know how you know how many
different you know different pfas you
know elements are out there but you know
even when you read you know you think
about car parts and how many different
elements of a car that might have this
type of beef house it's just it's going
to be a real bear to try to rein this in
representative Bartlett thanks to Mr
chair
um yeah I think that I mean from all the
testimony we had Des is certainly very
involved with trying to figure out how
many parts per billion is acceptable
um I think that this is way further than
what the state is going to be able to to
really um handle I what I've got here is
that Maine passed a bill they put 40
million dollars appropriated but we
tried to get information about
um
you know how how they were moving
forward with it yeah it's a moving
Target right now because they keep
creating exemptions and saying we're not
ready we're not ready we're not ready so
at this point it's p faster everywhere
everywhere and somewhere along the line
we've got to figure out one you know how
to stop the supply line and two in
communicating I think this bill I think
was carpets we had carpets was in this
bill and you know carpets I guess is
Scotchgard
right I think about how much Furniture
you know people you know thought you
know somehow great Scotchgard was a
so um yeah I don't think there's
something we can do okay
so the recommendation yes representative
yeah I just want to um add to that that
the wastewater treatment plants in um
all the towns and cities I mean it's
going to cost millions and billions of
dollars to get pfas out of our you know
drinking water so
um I think it's all about you know
funding we're not going to stop the
manufacturing of pfas what communities
need to do is address it through their
wastewater treatment plant to get it out
of our drinking water
and that's going to cost billions so I
mean it's huge it's huge it's not just
the sourcing it's it's the and it's
really a federal in mindset this is a
federal issue that that it's got to
happen Nationwide and we gotta so okay
so who would like to make a motion of to
or who would like to bring that forward
when we accept this bill for not
okay I don't want to get too far ahead
did uh did you want to speak to you you
want any do you want anybody want to
offer up anything yeah
yeah
I just I I understand that we probably
where we probably would have gone with
this bill but I find it distressing that
we're finding spending five minutes on
something so important as pfas and I
understand all the pfases and everything
but I think it would have been
a good idea to look at if there even
were small things that we could do
Statewide to keep it out of our water
systems it's okay do you have any ideas
yeah no I I don't think that this is the
place to just throw out ideas I was
hoping that there'd be a study committee
over the summer that would have come
forth that's what I was expecting ah
that would have been a chapter study
committee whatever you want to call it
well how long have you been a red
Representative no go on okay right the
difference between a chapter study
committee and an interim study committee
is an interim study is kept within the
committee and the committee is then
doing the work a chapter study committee
is uh is can be during the summer
and they invite people who are experts
in the field and get them in and make
recommendations uh to how to address
that issue so what you're saying is you
wish this had been a chapter study
committee rather an interim study
committee could have met over the summer
I not really clear why it couldn't have
well that's a whole other problem no we
didn't if we weren't doing anything but
resume now but no interim study is
totally different than chapter study
okay thank you
yeah I just like to mention that the
pfas issue as it becomes more and more
known by uh corporations there are
places where it really is changing uh
and one is the ski wax industry you
can't find ski wax anymore with pfas in
it because FIS has banned it and the
state of Vermont also banned it and the
other thing is that um I work up at the
Canon advisory committee with a guy
who's involved in the car wash industry
and I I've talked to him about simonize
and because that was one of the other
sources of pfas Simoniz doesn't have
pfas in it anymore they've changed their
formula so as people become more aware
of the problem there are places where
it's really beginning to change
so we just have to keep pushing them but
but I think you're just getting more
public awareness about the exactly and
what's going on but you know in New
Hampshire we're very fortunate you know
we're fortunate or not fortunate you
know because of peas and Merrimack that
it really became a Forefront issue you
know the piece uh because of the fire
retardant you know who knew that that's
what pfas was was all about was putting
out putting out fires and and they were
worried about the the airplanes
um you know their air cargo planes over
there they're carrying jet fuel
um so they they were they practiced one
too many times in terms of saturating
the ground with that stuff
so representative Abramson Yep this was
another issue where I uh didn't agree
with the the bill as written and but I
agreed that there was a problem there
was an issue and I I felt that this was
one that we kind of can of worms that we
had to kind of open up
um and we we talked about a lot of
different things maybe this isn't the
bill
to do it someone will come from
the next session will come up with a
different Bill who knows who the voter
is going to read voters will re-elect
but uh
um I mean we've talked over the years
about a number of different ideas like
putting a a 10 cent tax or something on
something so that shows up on your
receipt so that you know oh there's a
pfas tax you see it on the bill
everybody knows what's not going to
generate very much revenue for this for
the for the state but at least it shows
up on the bill or just a requirement
that it shows up uh when a business pays
for something that they can get some
type of notice that uh
this product contains pfast or a label
or or a sticker who knows what
um I recognize that the the bill
couldn't pass as is but I I felt that
something should be done about this
we're finding about out about the cancer
um I'm not sure if it it's not something
where we would recommend this particular
legislation but we do recommend some
future legislation
to deal with it right but as you know we
you know can't bind the future and
obviously anybody
who who uh comes back next year can
certainly introduce legislation right
that's why it's just a recommendation
right it's just a recommendation on this
bill as written
that's this bill as written is not
recommended it would be no well maybe
maybe this is more of a parliamentary
inquiry when we say we recommend this
issue for future legislation or we
recommend this bill as written for
future that's a great question uh in the
old days uh we actually had that option
in the old days we actually have
recommended not recommended or
recommended with with Amendment
and I'm not sure where I think this is
the second term around that where they
deleted that phrase from the Motions
that can be accepted
but we did actually have that used to
have that
okay I don't want to get too far ahead
so why don't we take a 10 minute break
okay why don't we uh start again
and um so I apologize I didn't make sure
I I sometimes my look in the audience I
make assumptions on who's in the
audience for what issues and and uh so I
I will make sure if you're here for a
certain Bill wave your hand make sure I
see you know that you want to talk about
it um offer up something okay but yeah
so the the the
conclusion is that we now know that
there are several commissions already on
pfas here in the state and that there is
model legislation being proposed and
being worked on and whether you know
whether it comes in next year or
whatever but it's it's going to happen
soon enough
you know I think this just goes back to
when we look at our files and we don't
always have our files in front of us
right
um the sponsor on this had consulted no
one
um he really hadn't done his homework
before he found the bill so
um that put him on the spot yeah when he
was here and it was harder for us to to
move forward on it because we didn't
have some of this information right so
yeah that's great thank you very much
and he was from Merrimack and he was
well doing it you know doing constituent
work
okay uh HP 333 relative to the sale and
distribution of Kratom products
uh as I remember this was a department
issue and uh you want to just tell us
what's happening you know within the
thank you um Abby Rogers legislative
liaison for the division of Public
Health Services I just wanted to remind
the committee that the department had
serious concerns with this bill
um HP 333 as the bill would have
um would have kind of categorized create
him as a food product and uh there are
no there's no FDA food product the food
code is regulated by the FDA and
currently there's no FDA approved use
for Kratom so that was one of our
concerns FDA has also issued warnings
um related to the serious risks
associated with the use of Kratom
um you know risk of addiction abuse and
dependence uh so we're and we also you
know had contacted the Poison Control
Center to sort of see what you know what
the stats were around calls related
creative and you know I think um in
between 2012 and 2019 there are about 94
reports of adverse effects exposure to
Kratom
um so as far as 333 concern is concerned
we have concerns about that we had
testified to such during the hearing on
the bill and just wanted to refresh your
memories that we we have serious
concerns with this bill great
so uh I have a sense that we probably
don't want to go forward with this
legislation is uh representative averson
you have a comment yeah I just want to
make a quick comment
um so I I did talk to constituents you
know person to person I did ask people
directly what their opinion was either
philosophically didn't also get a lot of
emails
um and I believe that this was uh posted
on online forums
um every single
um person I talked to or who emailed me
or reached out to me whether they were
using it or not said that they were in
favor of letting people do this I did I
think I saw one comment maybe on
citizens count or something where they
were against allowing it but but if
people needed it the the reason that uh
some people
were using it was
um to get off of heroin
um and that had
mostly positive results but if it even
works ten percent of the time I think
that that would be a good enough reason
to allow it and
um but by and large it was people facing
depression or PTSD and their doctor or
medical professional they talked to
psychiatrist
[Music]
um
said it's kind of you know prescription
drugs or Kratom
um and many of them recommended Kratom
rather than some of the opioids and
prescription drugs that were out there
so
um philosophically I believe that people
have the right to
eat or drink or smoke whatever they
choose it's their own body that you
don't belong to the state
but as on on the medical question if
there are medical symptoms if if people
have a recommendation that they use it
that uh that this seems to be less
harmful than some of the prescription
drugs or
worse just a kind of chancing depression
and a further symptoms
so there is no actual law in New
Hampshire that makes Kratom illegal
uh my understanding is Kratom is legal
for age 21 and Over
except for in the city say it again so
that was Asian sorry I believe that it's
legal in New Hampshire from if you're if
you're 21 to use kratom however the city
of Franklin is the only town and the
only city in New Hampshire that has made
it illegal for use right okay
you follow that Mike said it is legal in
New Hampshire except stay out of
Franklin
I'll reach out to the sponsor I believe
what he said so this is a going back a
year I think he said that uh they needed
it regulated for some
for some reason relating to uh uh
guaranteeing that they have so many
states regulating it and being able to
respond going to the feds if the fed's
ever tried to ban it
um so like I say I'm willing to go back
to the sponsor and get more feedback
fair enough representative okay so at
this point my sense is that we're not
recommending for future legislation uh
okay great
um
I guess I shouldn't have done it by time
certains
um next uh it's HP 1378 relative
inspection of public lodging houses
all right I'll start with it is there
anybody in the audience who here wants
to
speak on this issue or talk about oh
so I I know I assume she she's from law
enforcement and therefore would
recommend that we would not do this
legislation is there anybody here who
um I have to admit I wanted to work on
this bill I mean I wanted to because the
language of the statue was very archaic
uh because I'm pretty sure there aren't
too many hotels that actually have a
book that you sign in on since I never
signed in on anything
um but that clearly the electronic
signing that we have electronic systems
that we now have place at restaurant
that hotels have is is similar to what
that legislation was and then but then
as I I kept going over and trying to
figure how would I fix this how do I
modernize it it kept creating unintended
consequences so that then I so then I I
I'll fall back on one that I hate to do
it's not part of my nature it is that
there is plenty of case law around the
way this bill is written the language of
the bill the law is now and so therefore
mucking it up or changing it you know
with an obviously change case law but
since case law had there hasn't been any
glaring problem and that's usually when
we get to hear about it is that case law
that people come back and say the courts
got it wrong
you know and that wanted us to revisit
it
but at this point I I didn't see any
evidence of that so I'm I'm more apt to
yeah just representative yeah as I
recall this bill and
the discussion uh in in uh when we were
having hearings I thought we were
hearing from uh
law enforcement that they found they
thought we should pass this bill now I
might be wrong but
but
both sides from one person but I
remember there were a number of people
in law enforcement who said that they
that this was a way for them to track
people that they were they were looking
arrest and could somebody clarify that
so the issue is was that if you might
remember the testimony he was going on
about Nazi Germany and the idea of
somebody uh being able to say who who is
in your hotel who's that that the law
enforcement has carte blanche to you
know you know gestapo has the carte
blanche to come in and say who's checked
into your hotel
and and demand that the hotel turnover
its records or should you know show who
who is who is in the hotel
uh he he he was it was about protecting
of the you know the right of privacy
really if he's talking about the writer
probably that the person should not have
to uh you know that that when you sign
into a hotel you would hope that you
have some
so
yes great
yeah
okay okay so yo yeah once you please
thanks
that's it hi good morning representative
hot members of the committee my name is
Elizabeth Sargent I work for she
Infinity Capital group here today
representing the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
um in looking at this we did not ask for
this legislation to be introduced and
testified against the bill things are
working representative Heinz correct
case law
um is uh has been very helpful and we
think this bill is not needed at this
time
and I if you remember now that it's all
coming back to me uh the Manchester
Police Department testified that they
have good relationships with the hotel
owners and we do have trafficking here
in our state and other crimes
um they need the protections that are in
place currently so we would be opposed
questions
um I I apologize for uh not remembering
this that's okay
representative Abramson uh would I be
appropriate to ask yes you may
um so uh maybe it was it must have been
last session
um I believe
that it was another committee it must
have been criminal justice
um
police Chiefs or police departments were
investigating officers who
um they'd had Ex-Wives or ex-girlfriends
sorry it was on a domestic violence
issue
uh where the
I guess I shouldn't even say uh police
but the the
battered spouse goes and checks into a
hotel or motel
without this legislation is there a
danger that
just an individual officer could be
going around to different hotels a lot
local lodging without a warrant and then
trying to track down their
significant other
in other words I always look at uh
I always look at use of power as the
potential for abusive power you know
could there be an individual could there
be a bad actor out there
is is this going to be something where
she's got to remember to sign in under a
false name
you know they're using
people usually use credit cards or debit
cards to to enter if if her privacy to
kind of escape a lot of people who go
into lodging
um temporarily are doing so unexpectedly
to get away from a violent person I mean
I would I would hope
um that that would not be the case with
all of their training and the checks and
balances
um with departments and I know the
Departments have a good relationship
with the hotel owners so they're not
going in frivolously and asking to see
rosters of people normally they have a
case or there's a situation there was a
situation in Manchester
um a year or so ago where they needed to
help the people escape from the hotel
there was a situation so having the
roster helps them get to those people
and get them out of the hotel so that
they could
um take care of that situation so I
you know
I would hope that would not be the case
I would I would not think that would be
the case they'd be allowed to go in and
and wouldn't there be a problem if they
were to try to pursue a case that they
would the probable cause would issue
would come up yeah and the case would
get thrown out if there was no probable
cause for sure other than just fishing
thank you for helping me representative
so
so right now they do or don't need a
warrant
to look at the the roster of people in a
in lodging my understanding is they do
not need a warrant to look at the list
that is correct this legislation was to
require a warrant but
they're going in as a team to work on a
case my understanding is they are not
on a routine basis going to look at
rosters at the hotels
so what I'm asking you is there couldn't
be a case where a bad actor a Bad Apple
goes in
looking for an ex-girlfriend or ex-wife
or kids or something like that that
there couldn't be abuse of power
represent Grayson
thank you Mr chair
in the discussions uh the original
discussions about this this bill uh
there's a difference between a working
relationship that a motel may have with
local law enforcement agency obviously
we
this is a general rule like we all want
law enforcement if there's a bad actor
going that is trying to seek refuge in a
hotel uh we want the bad guy out of
there and so having a working
relationship with the police department
is common sense good for business uh if
you're known to house uh people of ill
repute
your reputation gets shot and you go out
of business justifiably so
the difference is in compelling someone
to comply
uh if if a law enforcement officer
tracks somebody into a motel after the
commission of a crime or it's a known
Suspect with a warrant out for their
arrest that's a completely different
issue from we think there's somebody in
there we're not really sure so we're
just going to go in and take a look
the the The
Innkeeper would have the right to say no
come back with a warrant
and then at that point in time I'll
comply
we cannot step on that right and that is
just proper police procedure anybody who
would want to thwart that I would be
very leery of is being a bad actor on
the police force they should be willing
to go and get that get that warrant to
compel compliance uh and so we're kind
of dealing with a bunch of different
extremes or different scenarios so what
this bill is trying to do is to compel
compliance
requiring them to get a warrant to
compel compliance I should say but we
should not eliminate The Innkeeper from
voluntarily compliant and so I think the
legislation goes beyond allowing for
volunteering
and only goes for you must get a warrant
in order to do this regardless so I
think it goes a little a little farther
than it needs to go and Innkeeper should
be able to comply I don't want bad guys
in my end come and get them but at the
same time if you want to force me to
comply then you have to get the warrant
and so I'm I I think the bill does not
need to be there any further legislation
because we already have the requirement
for a warrant to compel
as long as we don't eliminate the
ability of The Innkeeper to volunteer
thank you Mr chair I'm just looking at
the current language in law uh it says
that the innkeepers shall comply and if
they don't
they're guilty of a misdemeanor so
there's there's a penalty if the
Innkeeper doesn't comply
so I'm gonna I'm gonna move that we
actually need to we need to address that
I I do not like the idea of shall comply
without a warrant
okay
so uh the committee uh how many people
do you think we should have a
subcommittee on this next week and and
try to sort through this problem
okay yeah
okay so we will I will schedule
okay
um Mr chairman yes it occurred to me can
I ask a question
yes
how difficult or how long would it
actually take to get a warrant in a
situation like this
warrants don't take long to get
a couple hours I I agree with my
counterpart over there that this raises
some red flags with me as well and if in
fact the warrant is fairly easy to get I
don't see that that's a real problem I
think that it probably as as we look
into this and I'd be more than happy to
be on a committee that looks into this
uh I would I would put that thought
forward thank you so
um maybe we should just uh go with the
concept of recommend future legislation
and leave it at that
okay so we can still come back on okay
who would like to make that motion uh
I I just wanted to answer the members
question
yes so um I work when I worked in uh
road construction I worked with a lot of
police on detail and they would say you
know when the issue came up
if they needed a a search warrant while
they pulled somebody over on the side of
the road they could literally just call
in a warrant 24 7 and have it
immediately if they really needed it
there was some way of getting it just on
Mr chair yes should I just clarify yes
representative
um thank you so um
with this this would be
I I don't know if it's representative
Grayson or somebody would write he would
make a motion and then write a report
okay so we don't need to do a
subcommittee on this though no I think I
just realized we really don't need it
yeah okay thank you I had it all wrong
foreign
okay
um is anybody here for the grant State
uh to repealing the Grand State Paid
every time
can I ask some clarification because
this Paid Family Leave does not to in my
eyes is not really a true Paid Family
Leave I'm not I'm not sure can can maybe
Christy I think you know more about it
because I don't wanna I wanna be on
record that we don't we're we're in
support of repealing or not repealing
because I think it's very convoluted the
bill is or the State of Affairs
regarding the granite state paid leave
do you know what it is do you know I
absolutely know very well what it is and
and I see two people who walked into the
room who actually know more than I do
about the greatest Family Leave
um and you know you can the the
controversy of course is that this is a
voluntary plan uh but that we are
offering it to all our own state
employees
so uh and that we have done a public uh
you know uh a request an RFP and to get
people to bid on offering this plan so
the question is that not whether you
believe or not to believe in a family
leave program and whether you want one
to be mandatory or not mandatory what
this legislation was was to repeal what
we already have in place it's already
it's really just a and there is some
well
uh
it's not I I would say as someone who
was involved in this issue you know
prior that this is obviously political
and the political was are we going to
mandate that all employers had to
provide
the plan or could they in terms of
opting and opting out the only opting uh
when the original bill was proposed was
whether the employee chose to
participate or not
um but that this this legislation
um has become political because it's
been accused of being an income tax
because it would be a tax on employees
so yeah so there they'll I'll invite
them up but I just I wanted me to make
sure you keep an open mind
that we have this is our current law
this is current law so this bill was to
repeal it
so
but this hasn't been picked up until
January 1st of 2023. we'll have who do
we have if we have the Department of
Labor and retirement Insurance who will
love to come up and uh and refresh
everybody's memory about what the
we are missing one of our Three Amigos
which is the Department of
administrative Services
um I think commissioner Arley house or
Deputy Commissioner Keane will be here
shortly so anything uh that kind of
Blends into their area I'll defer to
them they should be here within the next
five minutes or so so just very briefly
um
they're going to introduce themselves
yes DJ Bettencourt Deputy Commissioner
of the insurance department
Richard laver's Deputy Commissioner of
New Hampshire employment security
and so as I said between our departments
as well as administrative Services we
each have a role in administering the
program
so just to level set for everybody where
things are at so this Paid Family Leave
program was part of the state budget
that was passed last year
over the course of the time between that
budget becoming law and now our
departments have been in the process of
procuring a insurance company to
administer that program that contract
has been finalized the state is in
contract with MetLife
uh they are in the process now of
putting together their materials they
have submitted their rates and form
filings to the insurance department we
have approved them
and the program will open for enrollment
that pretty much covered the basics
okay
and uh
Deputy Commissioner Bettencourt really
covered
what we've been doing from an
operational perspective with the laws
passed some additional aspects that
we've put in place
you know we've been
marketing the program building awareness
both within the employer community and
the individual Market making sure they
understand this is a voluntary program
that it's available to each and all of
them but required of none of them we
have our website was stood up back at
the beginning of September uh Paid
Family Medical
leave.nh.gov we've been seeing a lot of
traffic on that website we've
established profiles on all the normal
social media platforms that you would
expect when you're trying to build
awareness of a program like this
um in partnership with MetLife they
conducted a series of webinars back in
the middle part of September they did
webinars for insurance brokers to make
sure they understood the product they
did webinars for employers as well they
had
um nearly 500 Insurance Brokers signed
up for their webinars they had over 1100
employers signed up for their webinars
we have been in the process of putting
together additional schedules of
webinars with topics that will be
relevant for the time right before the
the pro the program going live with
coverage kicking in in January 1st and
where MetLife stands right now from a
quoting perspective and an activity
perspective they are a few months ahead
of schedule where they are right now
with the number of inquiries they're
Fielding from large employers small
employers
um looking to get quotes for coverage
they are right now where they expect it
to be in December so activity and
interest or building
and we're continuing uh to build
awareness for all of the groups that
will have the ability to to choose or
not to choose to have this type of
coverage come January 1st
and one last thing if I might Mr
chairman one other key component and I
know representative Ammon has a question
and it's good to see you well sir
um the last key component for our
department is separate and aside from
this program we were in the process of
putting forward administrative rules
related to uh Paid Family Leave programs
there is not currently a program offered
in New Hampshire that has the coverage
and structure of this current proposal
but there are some
very different skinnier plans that one
carrier did bring to Market which
generated our department to begin the
administrative rules process for those
products that is currently going through
the gel car process but those rules will
be in place if all goes well in advance
so I see it from administrative services
I don't know if you uh
one you could take this seat right over
here with the microphones because you
might have to talk yeah
is there anything you wanted to say uh
well before we take questions or you
why there you go Rich did you speak to
our implementation work
we're covered okay rich and I work as
partners on the project and have been
working on it very heavily since the
bill passed okay so just state your name
and oh I'm sorry sir Catherine Keane I
am the Deputy Commissioner of the
Department of administrative Services
great
we've got our deputies here
okay representative McAleer yes two
quick questions
um what are the specifications are there
different options involved and all
second question is is individual
underwriting done or is this group
so the answer to the first question is
that MetLife does have the flexibility
to go out to different businesses and
offer different types of
leave in terms of a number of weeks and
higher wage replacement they cannot go
below the threshold set
in the context of health insurance you
maybe call it the bronze plan which is
the six weeks 60 wage replacement they
cannot go below that but they do have
the flexibility to offer benefits that
are more generous than that
and then the underwriting piece the the
group the businesses will certainly be
subject to underwriting and a question I
get a lot is what are the rates for
businesses and it's a really
nearly impossible question to answer
because it's going to go through that
underwriting process and so if you own a
Logging Company your premium is going to
be significantly different than if you
run a dentist office those are two very
different types of businesses that
involve very different types of risk
but I'm assuming if you go above the
base plan they might also do
underwriting on the individual would
that be so the individual pool if if I'm
understanding your your question
correctly bear in mind that those rates
are capped at five dollars per pay week
and so the rates that were filed by
MetLife to us come in right around the
cap to a little bit below the cap there
is some underwriting that goes on there
but the risk you always have when you
implement a cap with a new program is
that they're going to instinctively go
to the cap which in most cases they did
but at five dollars per pay week that's
a pretty inexpensive
cost for the type of coverage that
you're going to get
okay do they you know representative
Ammon then
thank you for taking our questions good
to see you
um just out of my own curiosity how
often is the program put out to bid and
and you know how has competition
introduced into the mix sure so it goes
through the regular procurement process
that the state undergoes so in this case
administrative Services was the
department that put the RFP together and
they can speak to any of those details
uh we're currently the state is
currently in contract with MetLife for
five years
so the contract would presumably go back
out to bid it does have a clause that we
can extend for two additional years at
the same term so we'll see how things go
that's normally what we do in our
procurement process
but theoretically it could be five years
from now yeah if
four or five years hits we'll be looking
at are we going to go back out to bid or
are we going to be looking to extend I
do want to say that again I just because
I think so many people have worked on
this that um with regard to procurement
nhes has been working hand in hand with
Das
okay now represent Bartlett
Joseph
no it's not just for state employees so
it's going to be offered this program
they
they're automatically in their their
employer is already automatically signed
up and that and that benefit is paid for
the state employees are getting the
benefit paid for as they do with the
state is paying for it right right
okay now representative Burroughs okay
just two quick questions which you'll be
pleased to hear that
um one of them is I I remember hearing
arguments that this program wasn't
sustainable but perhaps that was just
when it was proposed as a state program
is that correct
I mean that's
I think it gives to the Chairman's
comments earlier I mean there's a
certain degree of politics that has been
surrounding this program from the work
that we have done we're confident that
the program is sustainable as it's
currently crafted and follow-up for the
question may inquire um and the other
thing that we haven't heard a lot of
what what's been the reception reception
to this program it sounds like it's
pretty amazing and um you know if you
heard from people who want either
employers or or individuals who want to
take take part in it yeah I think I
think Rich covered some of that our
department receives a steady stream of
interest
um you know I think it's important to
remember that for a lot of particularly
larger businesses they are self-funding
in some cases this benefit and so now
there's an opportunity for them to
become part of a larger program
obviously the larger the risk pool the
better the premiums will be and then
obviously there's a tax credit incentive
as part of the program which is going to
representative Abramson
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
uh you may have said this during your
testimony but is are you saying that the
the rates for those employers who choose
to come in is it the same regardless of
business industry so forth It's variable
the rates vary from one type to another
yep it is all subject to underwriting
so could it well could there be a huge
disparity between
you know one type of business in another
where another faces a very high cost or
well maybe if there are two businesses
in the same industry facing a disparity
and cost so so first of all
um when it MetLife is quoting for a
particular employer they're going to be
look at looking at the demographics of
the employee population for that
employer so that's one variable another
variable is as assistant commissioner
Bettencourt mentioned is industry the
industry there's a big difference
between working in a in a quote-unquote
safe environment like a dentist office
versus being in the logging industry so
that'll be another factor in
underwriting
but at the end of the day I'll be the
employer choosing whether they want to
go forward with the plan or not yes
which is critical from the original
legislation which was that it was
mandatory for employers to sign up
correct and and that is absolutely right
Mr chairman and what makes the program
uh Universal in terms of its access is
that if that business chooses not to
participate in the program but there's
an employee that would like that
coverage they can opt into the
individual pool
as a per right as an individual so
suppose group in individuals
representative Grayson
thank you Mr chair
why would it make a difference
who my employer is when this is paid
family medical leave
if I'm a logger or I'm not a logger my
wife is a logger I could understand this
is paid family medical leave so her risk
is greater than mine
I make candy
so my risk is lower than her she's out
chopping trees
so I could understand that but if I'm
chopping trees and she's making candy
why would it make a difference that I'm
the one who's chopping the trees this is
paid family medical leave not paid
medical leave let me uh if I can address
that the the
with any insurance product
um the way I'm Sorry Charlie Arlington
the commissioner of administrative
services with any insurance product uh
the task of the insurance company right
to make sure they don't lose their shirt
is to figure out what are the risk
factors what are the what am I likely to
going to have to pay out the idea is you
know if you think about insurance that
goes back to Scottish widows right the
the widows of ministers and they said
how many people are going to die this
year and we're gonna have to take care
of the the Widow and they did a
calculation based on how many people are
supposed to die therefore how much are
we gonna have to pay out so every factor
is an attempt to figure out how much are
we likely to have to pay out as part of
a benefit how much are we going to have
to do there are some Industries where
where some injuries to you are more
likely and and I can figure that out
because I might I might be taking care
of my knee for example
the likelihood of what exactly happens
with your with your spouse is harder for
me to figure out but it's something that
we're going to try to get a handle on I
am also going to try to get a handle on
how much how much of the of wages we
have to replace and if you happen to be
insuring let's just say for the sake of
argument a law firm where people are
making more money as opposed as opposed
to a different firm where people are
making slightly less money
um the the risk factors are part of that
so what they're allowed to do is to
propose rates and the set rates based on
factors those rates are end up being
looked at by the uh by the department of
insurance but everything that they're
going to do is to figure out how much
they're going to have to pay out so that
they don't don't actually lose money and
and that's all rate setting is ever
about is how much am I gonna have to pay
out
okay representative Terry I had a
similar question sir
um and in your response I heard you
mention injuries
did you recall that you just mentioned
that in your response as one of the
factors
I think I might have said yeah I don't
yeah well well transcript well you did
but anyway so so that's what I'm hung up
wouldn't be a worker's concentrate it
had to be a home industry a home in
injury in other words you'll hurt you
injured yourself at home or some you
know that rather than so this is paid
family leave this is not about injuries
yes
so
why would injuries be a factor in
determining the the premium rates for
for Family Leave issues when I think a
family leave issues the constellation in
current would would be well I I have a
sick I have a sick spouse so I need
family leave I have a sick child I mean
my wife is working full-time and and so
I need to be at home to take care of the
child so without doing a risk assessment
or maybe you are doing this or will be
doing this a risk assessment that
involves
looking at the relationships
that a person has who is covered under
Paid Family Leave
I I don't I don't see where injuries
come into play with respect to setting
rates
what the state has done is hired a
company or state has contracted with a
company or allowed a company to enter
into the market that's an insurance
company that does this for a living and
it's not me and I'm not going to figure
out what the factors are and it's not my
job to figure out what the factors are I
can actually answer the question but the
injury was a car accident
and they had to take to take day off to
be at the surgery
that's the family leave
I'm sorry Mr chairman who who sustained
the injury could could be either one in
other words that's if your family if
you're if your son is in a car accident
what if it's me and if it's you that was
in the car accident yes
and you're going to get insurance health
insurance to pay for the surgery
but you will not get paid for work
because you're out of work because of
the injury
that's what the family leave will cover
you for you now will get some
compensation for being out of work due
to an injury had nothing to do with the
employer you got into that car accident
all on your own but now you can apply
am I right you are right Mr chairman but
I will say I appreciate what
representative Terry is getting at and
that there is I think some confusion in
the label of the program
but in this program individuals have
first-person coverage which is to say
coverage for themselves in those
situations where workers comp but would
not come into play
representative Abramson and and just to
further what you said and answer the
question sometimes workers get injured
on the job and workman's comp doesn't
cover it uh they'll there's there's so
many different things that employers
have where they say or sorry the uh the
insurance company says well you are
going on break or you're going to the
bathroom or you're just picking up those
cones on their own on your own or we'll
say this as is linked to a pre-existing
condition or there's so many ways that
they can get out of just not paying
um and so some of these reference comp
cases go on for a very long time and you
have medical bills accumulating right
now
so so if I understand this correctly Mr
chairman while this might not
technically be blanket coverage it
provides much broader coverage than
would be available under working
example here you could have had Aflac
you could have had Aflac for lost of
anything in time but very few people buy
that product and so this is uh offering
that benefit to
employers you know would want to be able
to not feel bad about not paying their
employee so in this way they can at
least have a insurance product for it
well with workers comp you would have to
be injured on the job correct
if you are
driving around on your day off and
are involved in an accident going to the
grocery store and you can now this work
because of that accident under this
because you were going to the grocery
do state employees get any of this I
mean his system this is the whole state
employees are the foundation of this
program and this is the benefit they're
getting and I don't have to admit when
we first had this was rolled out and uh
where I first met Ridge and the
conversation was well if the premium is
low enough the employers might just suck
it up pay them pay it themselves because
they would want to offer it as a benefit
to their employees but the original
legislation always had that caveat that
an employer might opt out not to pay it
only had to do the collection uh through
their workers through their unemployment
form and that the uh the employer would
have the right to ask the employees to
pay for it but in this case uh the way
we got this
legislation finally passed was that
we're using the state employees as a uh
who this is a benefit that the state
negotiated with the state employees that
we're giving you this benefit okay and
that now gives the the fund the pro the
insurance product you know a basically
have some you know working capital to
get going forward but yes it's still up
to an employer to choose whether they
want to pay offered as a benefit to the
employee or whether they would pass the
cost on to the employee themselves okay
so so this extends a benefit to State
Employees have into the private sector
as an option correct the other thing was
is uh this has nothing to do with a
maternity or leave or anything like that
I would say maternity is part of it yeah
absolutely yeah representative Abel
I want to thank each and all of you for
explaining this uh we as a committee
we've tried to pay attention but weren't
involved in everything and
um you've really elucidated uh something
that is is much broader than I
originally I thought it was
um so I I really thank you you really
did a great job
um and I also can I just make a comment
certainly all right as a comment I want
to say that I haven't heard anything
today that would indicate that there
would be a reason to uh
to repeal this uh this uh this law
and I hope there's no one else here in
on the committee who wants to do that so
that's my comment okay
represent him thank you I just have uh
one question
um would this cover
an injury an accident or whatever that
occurred prior to taking out the
insurance let's just say
um it would only cover
um injuries or accidents subsequent to
having taken yes of the insurance yes if
I understand your question correctly it
would be analogous to not having auto
insurance getting in a wreck
calling up an insurance company saying I
need a policy and then putting in a
claim right
um
that's not allowed so if you do that you
get a call from our fraud department and
you don't want that and you've done a
good job of that this year right sadly
sadly we've had a lot of cases over the
past year
yes representative I think but um if
color could buy into this program
okay
um
we'll we'll discuss this you know I
think at this point where we've
discussed this fully I don't know if
anybody like to be the one who makes the
motion to bring It Forward
okay
all right uh past 11 30. all right
requiring employer to provide reasonable
is anybody here to uh
participate in the discussion on this
legislation
representative Abramson yeah I made a
point on this bill
during executive session where I said
that the only example that I could think
of
where employers are moving around was in
road construction where I'd worked
before
uh since then I now work in tech support
and I work with a lot of different
people who move around the state move
from place to place
um
and
uh it it appeared to me that you know
State mandates unfunded mandates they're
inflexible they don't allow for
exceptions and when we have tried to put
in a process for allowing exceptions
um it ended up being another kind of
hardship to create for certain types of
businesses and in road construction in
particular some of the some of the
companies are pretty small they only
have one or two trucks and to require
that they drag a trailer along behind
them was well the the unfunded mandate
issue definitely came up when it came to
school districts
and that
um there turns out that they are one of
the uh biggest complaints or the biggest
claims that have been made the teachers
were not getting proper accommodation
and and I have a real life story with my
my daughter uh where they were you know
they said okay if you don't want the
bathroom they they offered a closet
and said you can go ahead and you do it
right right well they're pregnant was
this was okay this was the time you need
three hour you need a break every half
hour every every three hours you needed
that's pregnant this is pregnant
was the Mandate of mandating time off
that you had to have time that there was
there was
I thought it was okay well what was the
issue then what's what's why what was
the
right
but I thought that even the pregnant was
the three ever half hour every three
hours is anybody
remember I don't know you want to pull
right okay so in this one there was the
language of when that the employer or
the how long the employee can stay
with the employer
and then they then they can then
leave
and the employer had to guarantee that
they would have a job when they came
back
but that the issue was was the employer
right I remember there was two different
bills I don't know what happened I guess
we it
I mean itl the other one
so
um
I guess that in terms of what I think
the issue was you know was employers
really not accommodating employees were
they not and how do you how do you
decide what is reasonable compensation
then you're going to get the state
involved
excuse me reasonable accommodating
accommodating
that the employer says I refuse to give
that
the New Hampshire
commissioner the director of the New
Hampshire Commission on human rights Not
Human Rights right yeah I remember yeah
Ani
right she had she was here for both
bills right exactly um you know usually
it goes to them first
um and they try to work with the
employer because they
their aim is not to go to court on it
um and for the most part that usually
works out the bill was to mandate that
employers need to work with an employer
the employee that is pregnant
and make reasonable accommodations so
they can continue to work
and the opposition was
um that they didn't want there to be a
mandate period right because of the
awkwardness of trying to intervene
between that employer employee
relationship wanted to continue
um to study this felt that women
are those that you know young women are
the ones that get pregnant and they're
the ones that
want to be able to keep their jobs many
employees we had testimony for many
employers that said
um
yes it's a good idea but others were
saying well I want to work with my own
employees and I um don't want it to be
mandated
the other issue came up regarding
keeping the job open and whether there
were complications pregnancy and how
long
that job could be
made available to the
um postpartum
employee right so we didn't kill it we
went we brought it to interim study the
other bill was killed in committee
conference right okay yes
okay uh representative Johnson was first
thank you so I I remember this um one of
the one most employees want to work with
their employees want to work with the
employees
um I did a lot of talking to several
several you know employers
um and if it does come an issue they go
to the human rights and they can usually
work it out in one of the biggest things
I had a problem with this bill was
um saying that if you are pregnant it's
a disability I'm sorry that is I mean I
can understand there's medical problems
that come up with a pregnancy I get that
but being pregnant is not a disability
and as a as a woman I find that very
offensive that because I was pregnant I
I couldn't do something and I was you
know a disabled because I was pregnant
it just to me it was
um putting a label on something that
didn't need to be put a label on I think
this is an unnecessary bill I think it's
already being worked out privately and
um
that's why I recommend that this bill
representative I just wanted so this is
a short Bill all it would do in law is
repeal
the sentence that says an employer shall
permit a female employee to take a leave
of absence for the period of temporary
physical disability resulting from
pregnancy childbirth or other related
medical conditions and then it adds an
employer shall provide reasonable
accommodations and or permit a female
employee to take a leave of absence for
a period of temporary physical
disability resulting from pregnancy
childbirth or related medical conditions
unless such employer can demonstrate
that the accommodation would impose an
undue hardship on the operation of the
employer's business
when an employee is physically able to
return to work her job or a comparable
position shall be made available to her
by the employer unless business
necessity makes this impossible or
unreasonable I do work by the way with a
co-worker who is pregnant right away and
she will she'll take her leave when it's
time to give birth and she plans to come
back when she's able to so
right so if I understand the difference
uh between the current law and this new
language is that the employee can come
and go
they can take a day or take days off and
then come back whereas the current law
simply says when there's time to go
you're gone until after you've had the
baby well it's it's another one where
it's you know do we ask employers to do
this or do we you know find them heavily
if they're not able to do it and I'm I'm
saying I'd rather program default
personally I'd rather programs be
voluntarily voluntary going back in our
history
um for about 100 years the Republican
approach on employee employer relations
Is we try to create more jobs than there
are people to fill them limit
immigration and create a healthy
business environment so that the workers
themselves can choose
all of the different things they want if
they want more pay or more benefits or
they want more flexible work conditions
that we leave it up to the employee that
we just create an abundance of jobs in
the marketplace that's kind of been our
approach I think that might even be in
the New Hampshire Republican platform
but that's at least for 100 years at
least since Calvin Coolidge that's been
kind of our approach let the worker
decide what type of employer they want
representative creason
thank you Mr chair
um
another issue that I see in the current
legislation is that there's no
responsibility on the employee in
communicating with her employer as to
what her intentions are at what point in
time after she has taken her leave of
absence she decides or doesn't decide to
come back how long does he or she the
employer have to wait on her to make up
her mind and you know to fill that
Slaughter not fill that slot so there's
nothing addressing any responsibility on
her part uh and I I honestly I don't
know how this is even a significant
issue in the marketplace where employers
are not willing to accommodate their
employees other than as you pointed out
the biggest offender is the school
system and so that's something that can
be done without legislation uh
representative Burroughs thank you um
maybe some more comments you know like
I do think that a lot of businesses have
human resources and they will be you
know if they want to keep their people
they're going to want to accommodate
them but I think of businesses like
these big nail salons where
um people don't feel empowered to be
able to to ask for or get what they need
and those are the scenarios I think that
we need to be concerned about and um you
know I I no disrespect um representative
Abramson you know he talked about the
Republican platform but you know this is
a bipartisan committee so
there's other there's other points of
view I I mean no disrespect by saying
that to you
so so the question is that a large
employer like a nail salon
I know there's a question about some of
those employees and and uh with their
yeah I did so notwithstanding that fact
the issue I guess what I'm hearing is
that what this legislation was attended
was that an employee would say I'm not
coming in today because I have
pregnancy issues but I want to come in
tomorrow
but under the current law you stay as
long as you can
and then you tell the employer or you
now need to find a replacement for me
but what this bill says is now the onus
is on the employer to have to be
flexible
that on any given day the employee may
or may not come in
if I could just offer a scenario again I
I don't have biological children I got
bonus kids through my husband but um you
know if a woman's really let's say
there's she's really nauseous you know
and she's just feeling so sick she can't
come in that day does that mean that she
you know she's going to lose her job if
she doesn't ask for that accommodation
I'm assuming
is that most employers
are hungry to hold on to all employees
they can and they would absolutely
accommodate them but that the way the
you know the the issue of the current
law and I assume the way the the current
law was written this way was an employer
saying is if you're going to take off
because you're pregnant
take off maybe if you're that close
you've got the issues I need to find
someone else to replace you I.E school
districts
I need to find that replacement we've
got to figure out how we're going to
replace you but to have to deal with
that that you could be here today or not
tomorrow or back and forth that
flexibility that the law this bill is
attempting to create is putting the
burden is a burden to the to the
employer perhaps a compromise might be
to do to to look at this the way that we
do
um I'm sick leave that there be
additional days for pregnancy something
like that might be something we look at
down the road I I wouldn't hope school
districts have that don't they I don't
know I I would assume they have that
yeah but in terms of to mandate that the
the nail salon have a policy I mean you
know
representative Abel
I bet you can guess what I'll say
um
I think that the objections brought up
are important to consider but I don't
think any of them are
so grave that uh with a little time they
couldn't all be solved
and I'm sure that this bill will be or a
similar bill will be coming up in the
new uh in the new session
um and I think that it would be right
for us to uh suggest that uh
future recommend future legislation
saying that that the current bill needed
some tweaking
um and that the idea
of it is is important and to tell uh
our female and male
citizens that uh that this is that we
recognize this as a significant issue
and perhaps and
I'm sure three of us can sit down and
could fix this bill so
um I would I would like to argue that or
urge us to uh to recommend uh future
legislation
thank you representative Bartlett thank
you Mr chair um we don't have the option
of recommending an amendment so we don't
have that option
um I think that all of us are at a
disadvantage because we don't have our
files in front of us with the testimony
of those that have been affected both
sides
um um on this bill and I have to admit I
don't have the file anymore
um
but I am going to I will be on the side
of recommending future legislation on
this one fair enough
representative
just to add to that um
if if we decide not to recommend
certainly an individual estate
representative state legislator
absolutely you can bring this bill in a
bill so everything we're just doing
today and tomorrow is basically
discussing whether
going forward if some that bill comes in
someone can say this is what the
Commerce Committee did in its last
action
representative
yeah I just wanted to point out there's
a principle that kind of relates to the
previous bill that we considered and the
magic word was voluntary so
we as state legislators we can we can
dictate what state employees are
required to receive
uh similar to the Paid Family Leave
program but leave it up to the private
employers to implement it voluntarily
that's sort of like the main principle
from the fame the Paid Family Leave bill
so
I think that's a good
okay
all right so uh representative Johnson
is going to bring forward the motion of
not recommended for future legislation
okay and
on to the last but not least and I see
Senator bertel is here
just in time
okay requiring online marketplaces to
disclose certain information to
Consumers uh
I'm I'm kind of well I understand why
but I was looking for Curtis Berry
because he made a he and I made a bet
about how many other states were going
to pass this legislation but but uh so
does anybody know how how many states
passed this legislation yet why don't
well we're not testifying we're not
speaking we're having a conversation
but you can come up Jim if you want to
we would never hold you back you
uh good morning Mr chair I am not Curtis
Berry but I am Curtis Picard so I don't
know that was close enough right
um and I'm the new head of New Hampshire
correct
um 13 states now have passed uh this
legislation California being the most
recent which uh was signed by the
governor I think within the last two
weeks okay okay
great so I would have lost the bet if
Curtis was here again
Mr chair Mr chair how many what was it
only 12 states that passed it at the
time when we took this legislation right
so it was only I think it was one stage
it was only a couple months ago yeah it
was only one state California right okay
may we have the the other 12 States
please
so what are yeah
what are all the states that passed this
I know that Arkansas was the first with
the with the permission of the chair I
have a map that okay that's good you got
Mr chair
yes representative Johnson get our
refresher on this one because I'm kind
of fuzzy okay so this one was to add
into our consumer protection statute
that a
um
a complaint could be filed to the
Attorney General's office
that the Attorney General then contact
the company that was selling the product
the enter the online platform
that was selling the product to ask them
to do a background check on the actual
vendor
that was supplying the product to the
consumer
do I get that right
not exactly this would mandate that the
Online Marketplace platform would have
to verify right but but the customer
before they could go on to the platform
or our seller I should say seller so
they wouldn't petition the AG they would
actually I thought the AG had to contact
the online platform to tell them that
have you done your background check on
this particular vendor so the AE would
be be the enforcement agency and if a
complaint was waged against the platform
for not verifying the AG would then
enforce the chapter right but that would
be the only time the AG would step in so
it would be a mandatory requirement
that the platform would have to verify
who is going on their platforms and and
who the vendors are who the third party
vendors are correct and and just so just
to kind of reset why that was the case
is I think we have found and we're
seeing evidence that
um this is the sort of the modern
technique of selling stolen property and
counterfeit property and it's extremely
difficult
for law enforcement to go after uh these
third-party sellers when they haven't
been verified they open an account for a
week sell their product disappear and
there's no recourse to go after them and
so this has been become a very high
priority for both the small and large
members of the retail association but
just as a refresher
Pharma is a strong Advocate and the the
consumer health care products
Association are strong advocates for
this as well because they are seeing
counterfeit medications and counterfeit
health care products finding their way
onto these sites where they're being
harmed and people are being harmed by
the products and the New Hampshire
Police Association you might remember
testified in sport because they see this
as a two-step approach to dealing with
these problems one
it will prevent many of the Bad actors
from ever getting on the marketplace so
the stolen products or counterfeit
products
never make their way to Consumers and
second if they do because the platform
has verified
who the seller is they now have
information to be able to do their job
and go after uh the Bad actors so those
are some of the reasons why this has
become you know such a high priority for
all of these groups and I think Curtis
even has some pictures that shows
some of the online products that are
being sold that appear to be stolen
products
um that came from Merchants where they
were stolen from some of the retailers
and are being sold without verification
of who the individual is selling these
products
so Mr chair these pictures were from
this morning I went on one of the
marketplaces and searched 40 miles of
within Concord and if you see from the
photos you'll see some power tools
multiple power tools being offered for
sale
um you know one of the things that that
we talk about in the retail association
of
things we look for for things that could
potentially be stolen goods is new inbox
unopened packaging in original packaging
those types of things or multiples of
the same product and so in this case
here you're seeing some Ryobi uh
chainsaws Ryobi is a private brand label
for Home Depot you can only buy Ryobi
tools at Home Depot for example yet here
is a individual supposedly selling these
items online in multiples and if you go
to the second page you'll see the seller
has no ratings whatsoever so I don't
know who this person is I don't know if
these items are stolen but these are the
types of things that would raise a red
flag with any retailer or organized
retail crime investigator the other one
is a bunch of string trimmers also
another seller without ratings as well
and this is what I found within 30
seconds of going online this morning you
can search things like Crest White
Strips Prilosec baby formula Gillette
razors these are the items that are most
commonly stolen because you can sell you
can steal multiples of them at once you
can wipe out a whole shelf and they're
also a high cost item where you can
regain now nowadays online about 90
percent of the retail value by selling
it online so 90 pure profit for the bad
Sellers and basically what we're looking
for for is every brick and mortar
retailer in New Hampshire is registered
with the state in some way you know who
the owner is you know their address you
know their phone number all we're asking
for is that if you are a professional
seller online selling Goods that you
provide similar information that every
brick and mortar retailer already does
as well
that's basically what this bill does Mr
chairman Mr chairman
question representative Terry thank you
the longer that you two gentlemen have
uh spoken and uh
enlightened us as to what's going on the
more questions occur to me about um
I I will I will confine my questions to
two at this point because lunch is in
view
uh number one
these uh these uh sellers uh this is
this is obviously a case of interstate
commerce
with these illustrations unless you're
going to tell me that these uh sellers
are only selling within the state of
they're located in New Hampshire and
selling within New Hampshire would it be
accurate to say as the first part of my
question that that we that you can say
that these entities are involved in
interstate commerce
they were attempting to they possibly
could I searched 40 miles of Concord to
try to find some you know potential
sellers that are selling within New
Hampshire
the reason that I ask
is uh even though I'm a big advocate of
states rights under the Constitution
if if if if this is happening with
sellers selling across state lines and
into New Hampshire that I'm wondering if
you could Enlighten us further with the
status of what's going on with similar
legislation to the informed legislation
at the at the federal level with with
Congress and second uh part of my
question is I see at the bottom of the
page of the handout each page that this
is uh Facebook Marketplace would it be
accurate to say that the laws the
informed laws are so similar in the
states that have enacted
the informed legislation that Facebook
Marketplace
could not legally be doing this sort of
thing in those States right now and that
they're not
so two questions sure so to answer your
first question first regarding you know
interstate commerce I think part of the
the purpose of this bill is to help
build a case
in that situation so if you're a loss
prevention investigator or law
enforcement and you can track down these
sellers maybe it's easier to build the
case that you're involved with
interstate commerce so it's giving a
state whether it's local law enforcement
state law enforcement better tools to be
able to properly prosecute these folks
um so I think that's helpful and um to
your second question what we're seeing
at the federal level like a lot of
things it's slow moving which is why
you're seeing States take action both
you know states of different political
backgrounds across the country are
taking this up I know Maine is going to
be taking up this legislation next year
as well so the more states that pass it
I think we're going to see better
compliance down the road but you know
retailers are asking for some help
and into the second part of my question
under the can Facebook Marketplace
in California Colorado say Arkansas
because it's been how long has it been
in law in Arkansas more than a year okay
so so what's happening in Arkansas
Facebook Marketplace do this in Arkansas
I would hope not but I don't know for
sure you don't know all right and I know
also some of the laws that have been
passed don't take effect until 2023 as
well
did I see a hand up over here
a year ago
um the eight the deputy one of the
assistant attorney generals came to
testify and he was opposed to the
legislation mostly because he did not
feel they had the resources or be would
be given the resources in the department
um to be able to enforce what this bill
would require the other question I've
got is Amazon is one of these big
marketplaces now online and
um
they my understanding is that if you buy
something fraudulently from an Amazon
provider that Amazon will stand behind
it is that correct so I can't speak for
Amazon uh specifically I know that
there's a lot of different marketplaces
out there and some are doing a better
job than others about policing this this
will help us regulate all the
marketplaces to be on a Level Playing
Field I will also add that I recently
met with attorney general formella to
talk about this bill he understands the
need for it I won't speak for him but if
we did have a conversation with him a
couple weeks ago and what was the result
of the com of the conversation I would
say he understands that what we're
talking about is to make sure that these
sellers are providing similar
information to what a brick and mortar
retailer is already providing so the
idea that it's actually going to need to
get to the enforcement stage is probably
a stretch but it's a tool there that's
available if needed so that would be
that his Department
the spokesperson for from his Department
would have changed his testimony if in
fact the Attorney General had been in on
that at that time yeah and I wasn't here
last year but like I said we met with
the attorney general a couple weeks ago
okay thanks but if I if I can add two I
I don't know
I remember the Attorney General's office
testifying I don't recall that they took
a position of opposition I I do think
some of their testimony was a little bit
confusing over on on the committee
um but I I don't think they actually
took a a firm position either way and I
don't think there was a position of
opposition but yeah I mean I guess we
could check the file to see what came in
okay so who's next uh Anita for us
thanks um
well as written now is ready to go
and and would you support it
we would absolutely support it yeah this
is this is this version is the the model
that is cropped up most frequently
across the country now okay thank you if
I can also add to that in the Senate
there was significant work done on this
bill so it isn't the version as
introduced stakeholders I think all
walked away feeling that this was a
workable piece of legislation when it
passed and that's why all 24 Senators
voted for it
so I guess the first comment I have is
um all these examples you've given here
does not mean that this law will
actually affect these people at all
because they're selling the product for
a dollar
and they have to sell five thousand
200 discrete sales and I would be
ventured to say that they probably
haven't sold any because there's some
scam that's going on and they don't
actually make a sale uh Mr Mr chair if I
could if you read the description below
on the top page you'll see let me know
if you see something you're interested
in and I will give you a price yep yeah
so the dollar is not the actual price
it's to get interest so how does it
again I I never even knew about Facebook
Marketplace until this bill came in okay
because I I don't have anything to do
with Facebook but and now I was
surprised to learn about it okay because
I always thought of Craigslist
and and
um what the problem being is is that
then the transaction now is between the
individual and this person who's selling
and Facebook has absolutely no idea
what the product was sold for
so again how does
this
the this legislation will never never
have any impact on Facebook because they
would always say is we don't track that
that's not our job we don't know
anything about that
I think it's fairly easy to go on to
these sites and find sellers that are
have multiple items for sale on multiple
pages and that's what we're talking
about so we're not talking about an
individual that's just selling one item
you have you know something in your
closet you want to get rid of we're
talking about individuals that are in
the business of reselling things online
so they have some sort of significant
online presence and we're asking these
marketplaces to just make sure you know
who these people are what's their real
name do they have a real physical
representative aberson
so my understanding is what you're what
you're asking us to do is to take online
retailers that are selling at this level
and you want them all you know brick and
mortar stores and online retailers uh to
be under the same basically the same set
of roles where we we can track them find
out who they are
and my other question is somebody
brought up interstate commerce as is in
the U.S Constitution if someone is
trafficking and stolen items is that
considered Commerce that's that doesn't
sound like something that would be
regulated we don't regulate illegal
activity that
is that Commerce if you're trafficking
and stolen because it sounds like
trafficking
it could be Interstate trafficking but
it would still be an illegal thing
occurring in our state I think if you're
shipping something across state line so
if you're if you're buying something
it's being shipped to you that's where
the interstate commerce would come into
play okay
um so I do want to give a disclaimer I
work in retail tech support right now
even though I work behind the tech bench
we see people shoplifting all the time I
can see them going out and sometimes the
cars license plates in Connecticut
sometimes it's in New Hampshire
sometimes it's in Massachusetts and this
is becoming the shoplifting issue and
then obviously selling it online is
becoming a pandemic and it is
jeopardizing the whole the whole retail
um all of our brick and mortar stores
about 45 of our retail store sales come
from out of state and we have one of the
largest
uh retail Industries in New England per
capita probably the largest because of
Arnold sales tax and uh there are a lot
lots and lots of jobs and there are lots
of businesses and and you know Trucking
and advertising distribution businesses
that depend on on retail this is getting
to the point where the amount of of
shoplifting that's going on and then we
know what happens to them later on once
they track are able to track some of
these cases down as they usually get
sold online or they may even get shipped
overseas
[Music]
um
but it's the the costs are on the order
of like two full-time employees and the
amount is going up and up and up every
year and it's becoming a dramatic
problem that could potentially shut down
some of our our retail stores
uh represent Grayson did you have a okay
representative ham did you have thank
you
I'm just wondering
um what is the
information
that you would need these types of
sellers to provide I mean register with
a Better Business Bureau uh I don't know
what what would give consumer protection
you know the person buying some sort of
protection
they are competing with the brick and
mortars and and what is necessary for
them to be
a reputable
venue under which to buy your products
yep uh the the bill details that it
would require the full name of the
seller uh or the company sellers company
name the physical address of the seller
the contact information for the seller
to allow for Direct on entered
communication a current working phone
number and a current working email
address
and if they're fraudulent then they have
to call the Attorney General's office is
that the way this bill is supposed to be
written no no if the marketplace is not
requiring their sellers right what I'm
saying is you you contacted the
marketplace
and the marketplace supposedly have
gotten this information
and you haven't and that that what what
they give you is fraudulent is wrong
then what's the next step what what's
the what what have you done so what
what's going to happen in this situation
let's take the Ryobi tools which is a
Home Depot product so Home Depot
investigators are going on these
different marketplaces tracking their
items they're building a case and then
they're going to go to these
marketplaces and say look we we've been
able to track these sellers right we
have questions about why they're selling
Ryobi tools right
what information do you have on them
okay in form act are you collecting
their names their address okay and then
so so who's going to make them take it
off their platform
the platform itself so you're assuming
that the Facebook that that if you
and they'll take this off they'll take
it down it will never go on in the first
place right if you can't verify who your
vendor is you're not allowed to put them
on your platform correct so you nip it
okay no no no no
they got fraudulent information
the person who put it on is not telling
him anything that's truthful
all that phone number address and all
that is all fraudulent
and you call them up and say Facebook
you know would it
I I'm a little skeptical of this tell me
which information you got
and Facebook gives you all this
fraudulent information that they thought
they had
that they thought they were in
compliance and you got this then what
what's the next step you called Facebook
and said by the way everything you just
said or did is fraudulent
then then what so I actually think and I
don't have the bill I'm sorry in front
of me but I think there's more that
needs to be verified than the four items
that was just there's a bunch of items
so again there's a bunch of items but
tax ID number needs to be and that's all
is fraudulent so in other words you're
you're expecting that Facebook went that
or let's take another big States
Pennsylvania and Ohio
that Facebook will have have made sure
this never got listed on their Facebook
that's I mean how why haven't they taken
them down why if the laws are already in
place why is this existing
so I think it is likely that that
example though that person is
negotiating the price directly that's
not the role that Amazon or
a third-party Marketplace uh does so if
this is like Craigslist we're they're
selling one item right they're not going
to go through this process this is
foreign
platform as an intermediary to sell
their product and actually do the
transaction so it really winnows it down
uh even further so in my past life and I
think I told this you this to you guys
before and this is the reason why I have
a problem with this legislation
and that is that I want our consumer
protection division to be focusing on
making consumers whole in New Hampshire
so I've always was offended about having
this stuck in the consumer protection
act first of all but second of all in my
past life I was an apple IBM retailer
and the problem of gray marketing
that's what it was called
the problem with great marketing because
they're always accusing us retailers of
being the great marketer
okay was which it could be these could
be retailers or great marketing or
selling these things are using this as a
strategy to sell okay but more
importantly was that those manufacturers
and and I hope after this you will call
you will have one of your you must have
one of your clients one of the your you
know your members is our sells this
product they have called Roby and said
have you guys ordered some of these
things and see and and see who is
selling it getting it from them my
experience was when it came to gray
marketing the companies found out about
it because inside every one of these
boxes was a warranty card
and the consumer filled out the warranty
card
and mailed it in and that manufacturer
would say is this guy's not one of our
licensed retailers
and then they went after them
and they tracked him down
so the ask Attorney General's office or
I'd expect that passing a statue in
little Podunk New Hampshire
when I bet you and I love to hear what's
happened in Arkansas that's I'd love to
hear what's happened in these other
states have passed this law
convince me that this law does anything
other than feel good that we pass
something
please
represent Grayson
the in our all of our discussions we
focused a lot of time on Amazon and
Walmart as being these large
marketplaces where third-party vendors
and they both your microphone is too far
away
all right I will be more of a loudmouth
then
those those marketplaces already collect
that data if you go in and look at their
requirements to be a seller on Amazon or
a seller on Walmart they collect all
that information already but one of the
things that is not dealt with in this
legislation and when you provide this
example on Facebook Marketplace not
everybody who is selling on Facebook
Marketplace is a business with a tax ID
number so you either have to require
every individual who's selling his car
or snow plow to get a tax ID number in
order to be able to make that
transaction or you can't regulate it at
all because Facebook Marketplace
is where individuals although businesses
do have Facebook Marketplace presences
but an individual person can get on
there and sell their individual property
uh on those markets so Craigslist falls
under that as well eBay is a little bit
different as they do require uh
different information and collect that
information uh and they do actually get
a fee for what you sell but Facebook
Marketplace is free and open Craigslist
is free there's they don't regulate any
of the con The Exchange that takes place
they're just listings of those but also
and on top of that this legislation does
not at all deal with the bill of lading
that says this guy has the owns this
property and has the right to sell it
and so if you're not you're not you're
just verifying name and address but
you're not verifying this could just be
uh whatever Mike in Manchester or
whatever his name is selling whatever it
is that he got uh maybe he owns them and
he has the right to sell them who knows
you're not providing any requirement
that he shows proof of ownership and the
right therefore to sell it and so we
aside from the enforcement that
representative hunt was bringing out uh
the the the legislation is really not
going to in in its current form is not
going to work uh because it oh it's it's
requiring information from
non-business entities
and because these individual person is
not a business
so representative if I could um the bill
does specify this only applies to high
volume sellers so you have to do at
least 200 transactions a year and 5 000
in sales so an individual just selling
items it would not apply to them right
and this guy just has 20 or so ryobi's
he's never going to get busted this is a
sting operation you just call them up
say yeah I want to buy one and then you
go bust him
that's what this is and that's the only
way you're ever going to nip this
and that's why we're asking for another
tool in the belt I mean both retail
retail loss prevention and law
enforcement have a very good working
relationship and but selling stolen
goods is already illegal you can already
go after them for that
like
uh let's have someone who hasn't uh yeah
representative Herbert
you put your mic on
so they have a they have a real issue
with crime and fraud
and they're trying to get some
information or put something I can't
hear what you're saying from here can
so
we're having a real they're having a
real problem with crime and fraud and
they're trying to get some impediments
in the way that might be able to
identify who's doing the crime and the
fraud which to me is common sense
I also thought about the ideas you just
put it up like this and then you get
five orders and then you go steal it
from the the vendor you've got to get
the orders first first you get the
orders then you go steal it and and we
had somebody remark that you just
watches that walk out of the store so
it's it's a serious problem the ID
number your social security number
all those things can be verified pretty
quickly so in other words if somebody
gives you comes in and to us one of the
platforms and and you ask them for four
things I guess I I don't I don't find
that actually believable I would think
before you could get on a platform you
would need a lot of information that's
verifiable but I don't see why uh we
would
be opposed to somebody coming in and
saying look we have a problem and and
we're going to say well you could do
this and you could do that and you could
do this that's their problem okay but
they had they need some support
they need some practical support they
need some political support so that they
know what they that we say okay you can
go after them all right they can may
come back and say oh we found this out
and it makes it easier to identify
quickly identify somebody when they're
being fraudulent
so I tell you what I think that's a
great idea and what I would hope that
when Senator Brazil puts his bill in
again next year that you guys will be
able to come back and tell us what's
happened in Arkansas and other states on
how they pursued this and how they were
able to find some bad apples out to
people who are out there who are doing
this and but I would beg you Senator
Bridge I'll do not put it under the
consumer protection act
it's put it put it in Criminal
activities you know that's selling
fraudulent materials but because this is
a federal this is a this is a cross
Interstate issue it's not consumer
protection New Hampshire consumer
protection problem
representative thank you
I don't know where my follow-up I was
just going to say what they're
introducing these for is just examples
there are thousands and thousands of
other examples the most of the
shoplifters who are coming into retail I
I understand there are some people who
are desperate for food feed their family
they they do steal from uh grocery
stores from time to time but most of the
things that they're taking from retail
are things that they don't need to eat
or or drink and and they're they're very
well organized we'll see them one person
drives a very expensive car and then one
two or three people sometimes they're
obviously drug addicts or something just
people they just picked up homeless
people they may have picked up and they
send them in to get very specific
products and they'll walk out on a
summer day with a big oversized jacket
with multiple things and as soon as the
guy kind of gets into the car they pull
all these different things out and they
keep them out of sight and we've got
some of them I've actually got photos
and and video of some of these people
doing it so uh there has to be there has
to be a way to track them number one I
don't think that they need to store
Social Security numbers and whatnot
maybe we can tokenize those people's
Social Security numbers or hash them or
uh that way so there's no way to trace
their number back okay so we're we're
getting near the end here and thank you
very much this is a crisis facing the
state right now okay representative if I
could just make a request gentlemen and
my esteemed a senate colleague when this
comes back to us next year it would be
really helpful if when you provide
exhibits illustrative material that we
actually have identified parties that
would be covered by the bill because I
think one of the things I've learned
here today is that this is not a high
volume seller illustration so it'd be
helpful if if you're going to draw the
line at a certain dollar figure in a
certain whatever that we see examples of
parties who are we would be covered by
the legislation that you're proposing
thank you
representative
could I make a recommendation yes I
would recommend that it um we recommend
it for future legislation
all right I think we've had enough of
this and thank you all very much
all right we'll now recess for lunch
and and I see that uh one representative
for the Liquor Commission here
um so
we actually knows digital assets didn't
we're all set with that right you know
yeah yeah
and then so we'll be like or so yeah so
um
we
will probably be back by 1 30.
okay
so we'll open up uh
and
yeah thank you Mr chair uh if you
remember 1502 was one of the
cryptocurrency bills like uh 1502
actually got folded into 1503.
uh somewhat for procedural issues and it
adopted the Uniform Commercial Code
article 12.
um that article has been updated so
there's a red line copy reinhale from
the bankers Association has provided me
with the redline copy of some minor
final changes so I'll be submitting
legislation just to polish that off uh
the bankers Association had a
cryptocurrency conference a few weeks
ago
and a fellow by the name of Ed Ed Smith
was there as a presenter
and he presented all about the Uniform
Commercial Code article 12. and he was
very excited that New Hampshire was the
first state to adopt the most recent
draft and he said that the the changes
will be minor you know shot and Tittle
type changes
uh so that's that's what I have in mind
I did want to say thank you to the chair
and to leader Osborne when I was in my
accident I had an accident I was in the
hospital and uh you both uh helped this
bill get across the Finish Line uh in
the committee of conference
and unfortunately uh Tom Sherman
Amendment got added to the bill but
that's okay I forgive you
the steel the steel the steel nonsense
but I appreciate you guys uh helping me
when I was not able to
I heard that was going around it was I
don't know I one of the things that I
asked about was how is that bill doing
he was really pissed off when he came
came to and he heard that that everybody
had to give me a conference walked out
of the room with nothing and uh so so we
did compel us to uh
uh use that as an argument to come up
with the compromise on Steel
um so so I guess I'm not quite clear
1502 we put into interim study but does
that it was just as a backup because we
don't need it we don't need it period we
don't know 1502 got the the substance if
it's there to modified for the UCC got
passed already in 1503. okay so but it
needs a minor revision just to keep up
with the UCC and that's what I'll be
doing yeah the irony the timing of the
the bills that that that's why we end up
using 1503 rather than 1502. so I just
we just kept 1502 you know you know in
that's right it was all about the
physical note one had to get out the f02
had to get had to be out in O3 we could
hold on to and then
put the UCC on representative Osborne
was the one who was spreading that
around the first thing you said when you
I heard that was being spread around
that I didn't I didn't try to I could
attribute it
fortunately he was strapped down because
some of them might get hurt
I was on uh some pretty strong paintings
but I'm still going to drop his name and
uh and then I went to the wedding and
and then up in Jackson and uh he was the
the the the the bride's dad was the one
who had actually contacted me for the
steel and it was everything was good it
was okay it was all he was all happy
happy because we you know we had caved
in and and that's what committee of
conferences are all about that's right
you can do good work now we can talk to
some of the other community conferences
which I did make everybody happy but
that one I made people no you did not
make everybody happy on others so yes
representative I'm just a quick word
representative am and I meant to come up
to you personally but I think all of us
are really glad that you're okay and
that you're here and that you're up and
about and walking thank you and and I
will note I got a card from the uh
Democrats on our committee I really
appreciated that but not from the
Republicans other other Patrice think I
Vice chairperson sent me two cards so
that was you made it up for it you made
up for it
okay so representative will make the
motion to not recommend for future
legislation
okay uh now let's do our favorite
subject liquor
first up 1556 relative to on-premise
off-premise sales at a beverage
manufacturer facility
so I if I recall correctly this was an
issue of if that after you've been on in
the restaurant of a beer manufacturer
and then uh on your way just before you
uh pay your bill you say to the waiter
gee I really like to have a six-pack to
take home
and the interpretation was that you
couldn't do that you had to then go to
across a wall or go somewhere else to
make that separate transaction and the
Liquor Commission promised to fix this
problem and
we're all good right good so
so we don't need that
who would like to make that motion it
was in for two seconds yep okay
all right
HB 416 allowing hobby distillation of
Liquors
so do we we ever figure out what it
do we ever figure out what it what it
was to get an actual Federal ex might
might look to the number so what it was
like 500 a year but I I wasn't sure
we never really pursue how much it just
to get that federal license right I mean
because we require you to get the
federal license to distill in New
Hampshire
so that that's really the threshold how
much is it for a New Hampshire license
that you're
right we did
so we made it even
yeah and why don't you come sit in front
so you can talk in the mic and so all
the world can hear you or I have Mark
yeah okay
because that's the the best title you
right they'll leave him back there
because he's just a lawyer
so why don't you introduce everybody so
we all know who they are here
hello everybody thank you again Mr
chairman uh for the record my name is
Mark armagedian I'm the chief and
director of The Liquor commission's
Division of enforcement licensing with
me today behind me is uh deputy director
and deputy chief Danielle Elston
Lieutenant Matt Culver uh who's in
charge of administration he's in charge
of Licensing for those questions these
are our new
uh I'm spacing out who just retired
so Scott Dunn is Danielle now right
Matt has been where he is right but who
yeah so when Danielle actually was
promoted Ben Williams is now in charge
of field investigations okay
the licensure who um I'm spacing on the
name who who am I think he just retired
yeah which would be under Matt's command
under him right okay so yes and what we
have done all I know is all the
licensees would always use his name and
because as you know Mr chairman we we
have done a huge restructure I think
everybody here and and thank you
everybody for being part of it
um and we've been very transparent with
it what we have done uh one of the
things we recognized in auditing was we
that our licensing group has gone from
when I walked in the door six years ago
of 4 800 up to 6400 today so we needed
more people and and we weren't get
getting more people because of the
economic time so we had to do some
restructuring and reallocating of
resources so what we did was that Jim
barbudi position is now a auditor uh to
help us out with that workload
um which falls under the sergeant now
um we had already which is on under mats
command so restructuring reallocating
resources being fiscally responsible I
think we checked every box off along the
way but uh but I thank you for the
opportunity and thank you for allowing
me to bring the uh the team as you know
this is a new team uh team that we put
together within the last six years
to to address some of your concerns
some of the concerns that came out in
the audit some of the concerns that we
have spoke about individually
and I believe at this point at this
juncture we have fulfilled all those
needs to include as Law changes we have
to change the rules that apply to them
which is something that felt a little
short prior to my existence here so
these are these are things that we are
very aware of today we are very aware of
the necessity for this division Vision
um and and what what its uh Prime
function is between the book markers of
its prime function and not to get caught
up with the uh items that traditional
law enforcement may do on a daily basis
um we have we have a niche so
um but your question on the distilling
so I'm jumping a little bit on you yeah
I keep going to the last build you put a
microphone
you put a microphone let's do the easy
ones first come on that's it so what is
the license now that would be able to
talk to us about the licensing pricing
okay
so the legislation that we just passed
we
made getting a state
license for stealing for someone who
does a de minimis amount right which is
300 and thank you chairman it's 300 it
goes down it's on the tiered system from
um all the way down to 300 based on
three products right so that state
license for like a hobbyist type would
be 300 but from 1692 correct okay
so that that's a
anybody have any other questions about
how anybody can be a home distiller for
but you still need the federal license
and some reason I had this 500 dollar in
my in my head but I don't remember I
yes representative Bartlett thanks Mr
chair
as I recall
uh
okay hobbyists distilling High liquor
well that would be the reason why why is
it that the feds
are are so zealous about just home
distilling was that what could it you
know are you gonna make moonshine that
poisons people right
so we as a committee have not been in
favor of this
uh I would have to say that
I wouldn't I myself personally never got
into worrying about moonshine because I
mean I'm glad you're not distilling at
the Castle I I am not just
[Laughter]
and you know because you could buy
distilling equipment you know off of
Amazon
too come on
but um but yeah so obviously your people
you know you do it and you do it your
homie and
hmm the ATF is not knocking on your door
and to see whether what you're doing at
home and the issue is always that the
the Temptation that you make too much
and be you know wanting to try to sell
it to somebody so the liquor
I'm sorry and I I thought Matt was
talking
speak to the microphone thanks that we
would uh oppose this uh just due to the
safety concerns that we do have and and
we're talking ABB we're talking alcohol
um volume
um and the proof of a bottle there's no
way for us to tell that
um on the federal level that is being
tested but uh home distilling has that
breaches that safety concern that we've
always had if somebody has
um some information on how that could be
done safely I'd be all ears to listen to
that and the commission would be all
ears to listen to that and the
it it would only be over your opposition
if the legislature passed it absolutely
right and I think and that kind of
rationales we're going from the 1600
down to 300 is you know that in terms of
the compliance you know we know we just
need to know who you are and what you're
doing and and you're doing it safely and
doing it safely so that's representative
Abramson
um if I recall correctly
um correct me if I'm wrong I
sorry I missed myself
was the concerns that were mentioned in
the
um executive session why we chose to to
retain this was something about Federal
jurisdiction versus State jurisdiction
if there's already a federal law on the
matter do we need a state law
should we should we or State Licensing
scheme or should we repeal that just
fall back on the federal version and
this one I I know that other state
legislatures have had to contend with
that question also so I'll be going back
over this bill and talking to the
sponsors again and getting their take on
that obviously and if you would like
representative
um and I know the other uh sponsors
um if you would like to have a side
meeting prior to that to talk about this
that we're all like with everything else
we're we're all ears
about um new hobby um
distilleries or distillers
um are they able to sell the product no
not for personal use right because a
thanks
I'm sorry I missed that part
representative
bring the motion to what
so
give the background on this so what some
of the mem okay so summarize what it is
we go into convenience stores out on the
Seacoast
um and small Grocers and they primarily
sell
beer wine tobacco and uh
consumers would go in and see for years
and years and years
Dusty Kansas spam Eight dollar box of
Cheerios sitting there until it's
expiration date
loaf of bread in the ice box and what
have you and they would they would tell
us the stories about how they would have
to hold this till the expiration date
throw it away
then they would have to run down to
Market Basket or local grocery store and
they would have to go and get new
merchandise and I thought and when I
talked to Consumers about half of them
from out of state
um they would say that that's the most
ridiculous thing ever this is Live Free
or Die State they the the perception was
that this was ridiculous so we we talked
in committee when this came up about
what if we replaced that with
you know who knows if there's an
emergency
roadside flares uh candles if the power
goes out if there's a natural disaster
or first aid kit some you know something
else uh instead of mandating things that
don't get sold so the pushback that I I
got uh I don't want to quote you but I
believe it was that there's not a single
grocery store or convenience store in
the whole state that has Dusty cans of
spam so I remember that something about
that phone call and I was so
flustered did I grab my phone but it was
my other phone and I went down to the
convenience store and I took pictures
with permission and sure enough there
were eight dollar box of Cheerios box of
Hamburger Helper sitting there and they
would go to their expiration date and
the other cashier would be like yeah as
soon as these expire I have to take
these and throw them away
so I was assured that that never happens
and then I went to the grocery
convenience stores themselves and they
said yes this this is still going on
even to this day so I was going to print
out photos and bring them in for the
chair but uh I for some reason I got
these mixed up and I thought this was
going to happen tomorrow so if you don't
mind I'll bring photos in for you
tomorrow
um because he doesn't believe me until
he sees photos yes I like photos but I
can also talk to some people at the
convenience store maybe have him call
you
because this is still an ongoing thing
on the Seacoast
um and I there must be people like like
spam over there because I can't find it
on no anywhere else it gets thrown away
no no
where I am most of this stuff that's the
Hawaiians over there so some members of
the committee were interested in instead
of the three thousand dollars in other
condensed cans of milk and hamburger
helper and Cheerios and fruit loops and
whatnot some of them mentioned interest
in well why don't we offer
you know other items again non-alcohol
non-tobacco items that that could be
things people need for example an
emergency first aid kits things that
don't expire things if your car breaks
down things if there's a natural
disaster
um and if members of the committee
wanted to go forward with that I'm fine
with that also but I I perceive the the
perceive the law and what I got from
feedback from constituents and neighbors
and business people was that this was
probably the most ridiculous law on the
books and should just be completely done
away with but if members of the
committee want to replace the dusty
Kansas spam with uh prepared foods I
think you said nachos and other things
that would apply that's all I see meals
and room Stacks but I don't see any I so
in the old days I used to see eggs and
bacon they actually they don't have that
anymore they stop carrying eggs and
bacon there's one they have Eggo waffles
there's a gas station and they have
sausages it still has hot dogs and
hamburgers that apply the meals and room
Stacks nothing else none of the other
stores going all the way up none of them
have anything on rollers
there's not no heated food at all right
but I'm right that's room and meals
you've been on rollers room and meals I
would invite you to come down to Hampton
Hampton Falls Seabrook take a look at my
district especially come down to
Seabrook and go down Route One there we
do have a lot of convenience stores and
see if you can find any hot dog rollers
because we don't have anything that's
under I wasn't suggesting hot dog
that was the interesting twist rooms and
meals food is not included in the 3000.
it was a complete opposite of that right
so okay so
we felt that this was a whole other can
of worms to open not that you should
open a can of worms I know this is going
to go somewhere they sell worms
if you if members no they might have a
fish it has to be a fish tackle store so
they would have worms they would have
night crawlers
if members of the committee want to
expand what's counted under the 3000 or
change the wording I'm open to going
back to legislative Services drafting an
amendment and expanding what you can
have in here
representative Evan
it was already touched on uh my
recollection we did discuss uh prepared
food and I forget why that was either a
good or a bad idea right but I'd be in
favor of expanding it to prepared food I
think that would make sense preparing
right
oh no representative Burroughs my
question is they don't have to buy spam
you know why don't they buy something
like chocolate that that's gonna sell I
mean nobody wants to eat Spam the reason
that they gave was
uh they don't want to sell anything from
there anyway so they just get a bunch of
stuff that sits there on the Shelf until
it hits its expiration date they throw
it away they go get some new stuff it
it's so I I we can ask the license
people but I believe
under our statute they have to show that
they have bought three thousand dollars
worth of inventory on an annual basis so
they it so
and I guess
in your experience have you ever seen
someone showing you the slip that said
they bought it at Market Basket rather
than from Cisco or well no they're on
strike right absolutely and thank you
for the question they they do buy it at
um other retail stores and bring it into
their stores for for resale I think that
an important item to note here is
historically speaking this three
thousand dollar Wholesale grocery stock
came in
um to help prevent the package stores
where you would have 16 coolers of beer
in wine and have a box of Slim Jims on
your counter so the legislation at the
time that they passed the original bill
was to say okay we're forcing you to be
a legitimate grocery store or
convenience store and that was the
intent and there is no doubt there's
probably licensees throughout the state
that have
um
uh stretched the intent of that quite
quite a bit but we're talking about 1411
licensees that this applies to so the
the number of
licensees who are are taking advantage
of that portion I I think are relatively
small
but the um and I guess in terms of the
conversation from what he has said and
I'm hearing is that
in terms of the inventory we were we
were focused on food
and mainly because we probably were
focused in on we have a food requirement
for our on-premise licensees that that
should be a food requirement for an
off-premise licensee but if we were to
take it further and say okay if the
off-premise licensee had motor oil and
had candles and flashlights and other
bottled water other things that would be
good for emergencies that you know would
that could that uh be a new way to look
at that three thousand dollars I Mr
chairman I don't think we ever said that
these uh convenience stores let's call
them uh our combination licenses
licensees can't carry other items but I
think we're losing our our focus on the
fact here and that's we're breaching
safety when we do not sell food in those
establishments I can't the the group
that you have talked to representative
to be quite honest about it they're my
focal group on education because they
don't recognize that on an empty stomach
if food is not not whether it's prepared
or not but if it isn't available to the
patron that the alcohol that they
consume could do a quick dump the a
quick dump into their small intestines
and end up in their blood system
immediately which are those people as we
remember and I apologize for my back
um those those people that remember that
could be quite fine at one point and
then all of a sudden out of nowhere they
are extremely intoxicated and it's
because there's no food there's no
coffee filter in their system and this
breaches one of the two of three uh
items that I've always said in the last
six years Community safety we only
regulate to the level of community
safety Industry Safety and to keep an
eye on our vulnerable vulnerable age
group and when you do not have some sort
of food I get it flares I love it
uh insta inflate for tires I think they
should be there but you can't first aid
kit but you can't take away from the
food that is actually creating a barrier
of absorption into the body
physiologically you're causing all kinds
of problems that we'll see we'll see the
adverse effects on our highways and we
don't want this I know this group
doesn't want to do that my group doesn't
want to do that I know the group I came
from Department of Safety doesn't want
to see that so that that is the only
reason why it's there so my concern is
that there are people that think this is
stupid and stupid's a heavy word that's
my education that those are the people I
need to get to with education
uh I appreciate it though so I just I've
never well I've never seen someone
get a 30 pack of Pabst Blue Ribbon
hit the road oh and while they're at it
get a box of stroganoff
get an eight ball dollar boxes Froot
Loops I've never seen it this what we're
what I'm seeing and I've lived all over
the state some okay some places do
actually sell this food
but a lot of the grocery stores I see
the food just sits there and they
deliberately pick items to minimize
their loss and minimize their work and
it's just stuff that sits there till
it's expiration date you throw it away
and having food having food I hate
seeing food wasted that's a personal pet
peeve
having stuff just sit on the shelves
until it expires and then they throw it
away and go to Market Basket Market
baskets open until eight convenience
store is open till nine
I I can't see doing this just because
there's a window of one hour where
someone is a
presumably drunk driver who hits it goes
to a convenience store that's very far
away from home
and is going to down multiple beers on
the way home
and then that that's going to be one
percent safer with him holding a box of
Hamburger Helper in there it I I can't
see the logic of it here's a here's a
question I have for you Max
would you be okay
with representative ammon's request that
instead of having a three thousand
dollar food uh requiring with this list
of potential things that people have
that they have at least three thousand
dollars of food that is a room in meals
is taxable by rooms and meals and
therefore it would be a snack it would
be that grinder it would be that burrito
it would be I've seen even because
that's something you might actually eat
on the way home would you feel better
about that I talked to one convenience
store owner about that that very
question and um
following the wording as well as I can
remember
I thought it was they had hot dog
rollers at one point and they couldn't
get
they they couldn't sell enough of those
they lost money they finally gave up on
it if we just narrowed it down and
restricted it to only prepared foods
that run to the meals and rooms tax that
would be an even heftier mandate for for
some businesses so it would be an even
higher cost well they could do both but
we're saying that include included
because that was where the pushback was
for the committee was that rooms and
meals tax type food were not on the list
and we're saying is well wait a second
isn't that the whole point is to have
food that they might actually
grab and eat on their way home before
they open up that six-pack because
they're going to wait till they get home
before they have one of those hot dogs
that's a lot of nice no no I don't know
about hot dogs for you the only one I
know who has hot dogs is Cumberland
Farms and Irvings you know the big the
big guys have the hot dogs a lot of the
when I in the ones I've seen I mean I've
you know in terms of smaller ones I they
actually have foods that you microwave
and they have a microwave right there so
you heat them right up and they have
frozen burritos I've seen cheeseburgers
I've seen I guess I haven't even seen a
hot dog that you can microwave it and
then they put it up so so we're talking
about things that would be I mean I I
guess the problem with it could be
danishes right danishes are taxables
rooms and meals you could have some
really you know High carbureted you know
maybe some things are not so good for
you but but the idea is that that allow
that three thousand dollars to be things
that that it would be good things for
them to be eating on the way well I'm
willing to work with the representative
Ammon and Terry let's see what
representative Terry has to say feedback
from that well I just I didn't volunteer
but I'm I want to add I want to make I
wanted to ask a question it seems to me
I hear the concerns here for safety uh
and I appreciate that
I'm also hearing that uh the the
proprieties of these stores are saying
that they're not selling the product
that they're required to stock
or presumably safety concerns
so they're taking a hit because they're
not selling the product well that would
be a problem because they have to show
that they have three thousand that's
right so you must be selling something
so so does it yes no they just have to
have three thousand just ask that
question and he said yes they must show
on an annual basis that they have sold
three thousand you're saying that these
that's not if so so isn't the solution
yes let's hear clarification make sure I
understand I didn't finish mine yes so
I'd just like to finish so it would seem
to me that the solution here to satisfy
both safety and
uh profitability all right we have two
concerns here safety and profitability
so uh we I would think that we would
want to to ask the Proprietors what is
it that you're carrying that's not
selling and what is it that you're
carrying that you are selling and what
more could we require or permit you to
sell so that you wouldn't have to be
going out and replacing boxes of
Cheerios that you went to Market Basket
to purchase to satisfy the three
thousand dollar uh inventory uh
requirement minimum
and and so the question becomes for
future legislation
how can you get to 3 000 at least and
have the stores actually selling not
only the product that's regulated but
also the food that for safety concerns
are part of the regulations
fair enough and and and then it becomes
a consumer issue because you could still
have people coming into that store you
could have a hundred people a thousand
people coming into that store and they
don't care what you've got up there you
you could have Twinkies up there or or
or or or or dried hamburgers or whatever
you know the unless it's the Rage or for
for buying at a convenience store
they're still not going to buy this
stuff but what we've done is we've
satisfied Our concern that we have
provided the opportunity for people to
actually purchase something to put into
their stomachs while they're consuming
the the alcoholic beverages so
ultimately it's going to come down to
the consumer and our challenge is to
find products that we think that the
consumer will purchase in the
convenience store and that's where we
need help what are those products so
that we can amend the list to include
those items does this make sense there
are a couple that the commission can
tell us maybe you could start by telling
us what is on the list now so so thank
you Mr chairman representative thank you
this is great feedback
um and I think all of you know that uh
the feedback is extremely positive and
we take it to heart uh first and
foremost uh snack foods are uh within
liquor 40402.
so they they sit in all this sits and
Rule already
so the stuff we're talking about doesn't
really need legislation it may need a
tweak of the rule uh and gel card to get
involved but that's it what's in what's
in the rule now the one that would
actually pick this the the prepared
foods up would be snack foods
um because I'm looking at bread meat
products uh fresher can dairy products
to include milk cereal products whether
hot or cold vegetables uh Canada fresh
fruits whether canned or fresh and snack
foods which picks up the the foods that
you're talking about that are pre-made
Foods on on the the roller but
um this is something that uh Simon and
and our group have talked about this is
not something that is wanted by the
convenience stores
so we're talking about well he
represents big convenience stores I'm
assuming Max is talking about the small
mom and pop one one store locations
representative
okay how many have are only one
locations
yeah
okay
yeah well you they're they're the big
guys here but but I I think
um to to be uh legislatively responsible
from the liquor commission's point of
view
um we could clean this up and roll
we appreciate that you could clean up
and Rule I guess we we would I mean I
would just say just on just from what I
just heard
um my wife would say canned foods are
not good and you should at least have
Frozen Foods so maybe vegetables and
that should be Frozen not canned but
having said that the question is for
representative Amerson because he will
not be back next year so representative
Terry is going to put in a bill for you
that you have to figure out what is it
that uh in the food category
okay we've just agreed you've just
discussed that we don't want to have all
those other things that you mentioned
that we want to have food and we want to
have food that someone is apt to pick up
while they're buying that six-pack
so you need to put your thinking cap on
go into all these convenience stores and
find those foods that you think people
want and then
he can work on that legislation and
hopefully we can solve it through rule
rather than a new statute but that we
need to know from what representative
Terry said to everybody we need to know
what is it that they're comfortable
selling
that the consumers actually want and the
co-sponsors will be by Lottery they'll
be chosen by Lottery because I'm sure
there'll be so many okay represented
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman can we
still get an explanation of exactly what
the three thousand dollars consists of
stuff get that get I want I want to know
what that three can you send send us
that list yeah just that's that is that
by that's by rule now correct so it's
rule anyway so we're changing and if you
could give us some examples of what
would not be included currently
so you know I mean I'm just going to be
ridiculous here but let's just say uh uh
uh a bag of peanuts shell you know a
whole shelled peanuts which the people
who typically Munch with beer or
whatever but if for some reason shell a
bag of shelled peanuts are not on the
list you know we we need to know is what
you have in mind as unacceptable
currently as well as what's acceptable
thank you vegetarians like the peanuts
so
Mr Chicken can you answer this yes yes
representative I was going to say when I
first
deferred that uh it might be something
we could defer just let the Liquor
Commission come up with changes and the
reason is I'll read it's a one sentence
uh requirement it says under definition
of grocery or convenience store
such establishments shall have and
maintain groceries which are readily
available to the public the wholesale
value of which shall not be less than
three thousand dollars exclusive of
cigarettes magazines newspapers wine and
beverages such groceries shall be
representative of grocery items commonly
found in such stores so my
interpretation of this originally was
that they could get three thousand
dollars of
anything from Market Basket or Hannaford
that they could get three thousand of
anything and what's what what's happened
is that the The Liquor Commission has
interpreted this as that they've had to
come up with their own set of
restrictions only narrowing it down they
created a rule around it and that the
rule seems offensive to you uh it's it
can be too restrictive in other words if
you just said if we if we just said
we're going to follow the legislative
intent of the law itself we might not
need a change in the law to just say
sorry to just say it's representative of
anything that's found in a grocery store
which is essentially what the the
wording of the statute is if we just
follow the wording of the statute that
would give them three thousand dollars
of whatever is in there other than
obviously beer wine and tobacco
and and Mr chairman and thank you
representative both both of you and all
of you
um I I will tell you this uh that was
representative of of the law and and I'm
sure back in the day when that was
written and authored it was agreed upon
um I think a majority of you know that
in in the six years we have written the
1100 500 200s uh 700s and we're in the
middle of the 600s right now we have
Rewritten all those rules
um and with with the best intent of
being as close to the current day as
possible and not back in 1934. So if
this is one that needs to be changed
there's no adversarial
uh contact here with the Liquor
Commission we we want to change let's
just talk about how we change it I'm
okay with that okay we all are chairman
you're going to get rid of canned beans
we don't want canned food we want Frozen
Foods all right we're healthier for you
I'm willing to work with them and I'm
willing to work with members of the
committee to absolutely so the
understanding would be is we're going to
say not recommended future legislation
not because we don't agree with the
underlying concept that the department
needs to change its rules on what foods
are appropriate for this statute Mr
chairman upon re reading the legislation
and the clear wording that I believe
that I heard from representative
Abramson it is it is hypothetically
possible that since we're talking about
items that are comparable that are
comparably sold in a grocery store that
that the rule that may come back to us
is is actually going to be reflective of
that clear here language that provides
for a broad range of products rather
than to have to provide a laundry list
of products or categories because
there's a lot more sold today in a
Hannaford or Market Basket than back in
the 1930s when they didn't even exist
thank you very much representative yes
thank you we're going to make a few
points
we're gonna have to change the
definition of a convenience store if we
make some changes here because I just
reviewed the definition
in regards to prepared foods you're
going to get you're going to have to get
a license from the health department
you're going to have to have a three
base sink you're going to have to spend
a lot of money to include which which
may work out it may work out they might
want to do it
um and the third point
if you're a business owner and you want
to make money you're going to sell what
people want I would think recording I
would think so too so if you have spam
and you have something else and people
aren't buying it then don't sell it sell
something people want to buy in your
neighborhood I agree and I believe that
prop I I would say that most of the you
know convenience store owners are going
to want to sell what they want to sell
um according to the you know the rules
uh but don't you know it depends where
you are if you're in Manchester if
you're on Beach Street or Union you're
going to be wanting to sell more food
than anything else well and regrettably
with every passing day it's going to be
easier and easier to reach a three
so that's my two cents
or harder and harder to sell it
yep
um thank you very much and to me it
doesn't seem very difficult
um to come up with three thousand
dollars worth of items that
um appeal to the same Market as somebody
going to the convenience store to to buy
beer I mean you could do it with 600
bags of potato chips
um it to me that would wouldn't qualify
they couldn't come up with some product
line specialized in snack foods it has
to be
how long is the rule can you read us the
rule
certainly
it's liquor 40402 grocery or convenience
stores combination licenses
sub paragraph a license licensees
licensed at grocery stores under RSA
178.18 shall have and maintained readily
available to the public representative
grocery stock
which includes number one bread products
number two meat products whether fresh
or canned number three dairy products
including milk number four cereal
products whether hot or cold number five
vegetables whether canned or fresh
number six fruit whether canned or fresh
and number seven snack foods
so could you have all of your inventory
and snack but you got to have one of you
got to have items in every one of those
categories that's the that's the catch
so that's why it's not just chips so the
three thousand dollar Wholesale grocery
store stock restriction is not that
they're selling three thousand dollars
in Wholesale grocery stock they have
that they have it at inventory correct
but as a representative uh pointed out
as you start including more and more
things such as the prepared foods that
now Food Service licenses are going to
apply there
so whereas we don't require a
convenience store to have a food service
license right now for the purposes of a
liquor license they will have to have
this for if they start serving prepared
foods and repair foods are part of these
restrictions so your interpretation and
application of this of this rule is such
that you must have at least one item in
each of those categories Cream of Wheat
right you can't just those items have to
be representative of the three thousand
dollar wholesale group so you'd have to
have one dairy product to meet the
minimum for dairy products that's
correct right you you so you're forced
to have at least one item in each of
those categories in order to be
considered a convenience store for the
purposes of being able to sell
liquor
that that's correct okay
thank you
so obviously we'd love to have this
solved by rule
yes um and and
but then the the devil's in the details
with a was represented below points out
that when you get into prepared products
now you've opened up a new can of worms
because you're going to have to have the
food you got to have a license to have
prepared foods which means you have to
have a industrial kitchen with that
special water treatment you know the
sewer system and all that nine that we
learned already when it came back to
food trucks
so we've already learned all that
problem so
so
sorry we're quoting on this in two weeks
in two weeks so we're we're in terms of
whether they get solved the next two
weeks the issue is the way your bill was
written which was to remove the three
thousand dollar requirement altogether
is not a good idea we want we want some
food requirement
I think I mean how do people feel is
that yeah we're not going to do it today
we're not going to do it today well I'm
going to have to talk to other members
of the committee and I'm going to have
to talk to the commissioner but that's
that you have our commitment to to
knowing so well that you won't be with
us you know we will work on getting this
issue solved in a way that that we will
never see spam again
right nice could I just mention
something on this very quick
I think one thing to note is how that
the representation that you're making is
not how we suggest that this is applied
in the field in the field when we do
these inspections and when we approve
these convenience stores we've had
several convenience stores throughout
the state who have said
do I have to do the can of spam and the
can of corn and we say no bring us what
you'd like to do you know we've
substituted granola for cereal I mean
some of the some of them get so granular
in what that what they think that
definition is and it's not how we ask
them to apply that rule so you will see
convenience stores in the state that
take it literal that that's a can of
spam or a can of meat and we encourage
them to I heard the word can one too
yeah there's just something to note that
that is not how we we want them to apply
to apply the role we encourage them to
give us a business plan right but it but
the what bugs me was and I this was true
first time I ever heard it was that you
had to have some representation in each
of those categories
so when it comes to a meat product
you know it's either in my mind it's
either Frozen or canned the idea of
having fresh meat is now you've got the
now you've got the uh the the town's
code enforcer all over your back
so representative Bartlett I guess my
feeling is this is an interim
study not a full-blown public hearing to
make this bill
better better or pass it or any of that
I think we're we've put a tremendous
amount of time and discussion that
really belongs in full public hearings
and I just don't think you know that
this this amount of going down this
rabbit hole is is worthwhile okay fair
enough
all right we all said
okay so who's bringing in the motion
okay
so the question was it's the language
and the bill is not recommended but that
the committee feels legislation that the
department needs to change its rules
to be more up to date with what is going
on in convenience stores I'm sure that
uh the secretary will note that in the
notes of the meeting and that will be
preserved and we'll honor that as we can
go forward are you willing to make that
motion then what am I making the most
not recommended as as written not
recommended is written but that the
department will revise its rules
to bring it up to uh items that well I
would say but but we we acknowledge that
the department
uh has indicated that they will work on
revising the rule to reflect our
concerns correct yes everybody okay with
that that's fine yes
yes
and that'll go
that goes in the blurb there's actually
a blurb when you make these motions all
right
okay
all right well remind me of them
write a minority just so there's a
minority no you want to write that
majority report I mean no I I you can't
the way your wording which was you want
to remove the dollar amount I want to
remove your bill removed the dollar this
is what I'm saying I want to remove that
sentence because it's a mandate that the
public perceives as a stupid rule okay
just so you know there are no minority
reports okay okay
moving on last but not least
okay
um eliminating the enforcement division
of the Liquor Commission is this
actually debatable I mean do we actually
have to have a discussion on this or
there's other people is there anybody in
the room think this is a good idea is
anybody in the room think this is a good
idea
my recollection of the public hearings
there were some members of the finance
committee that came to testify but after
the hearing was over I saw all of you
shaking hands and being very friendly
with one another so I think the issue
got worked out and it has to do with
reports being available and made public
so so my recommendation would be uh not
recommended for future legislation uh I
can leave it at that all in favor thank
I don't think there's anybody
I think we took care of it okay yeah
representative is going to make the
motion I'd like to move forward okay HB
1591 I move that there is no future in
doing anything about eliminating the
enforcement division of a Liquor
Commission
for mainly two reasons
one the enforcement division also
engages in education which has become a
very hot primary topic with our use of
today
and I think they're doing an excellent
job on doing it and getting rid of it
and changing it to just an education
division would limit their activities uh
in the especially in the enforcement
side which is also quite active now with
the uh the drug and alcohol problem that
we've had we're having this state and
with illegal drugs especially and that
thank you representative
you know we're done here
we're done uh you know execs you'll all
have your emails uh we'll tell you that
the exact session has been moved up a
week
you tell me we're meeting tomorrow too
so it's tomorrow and then Wednesday and
Thursday yeah okay
it see it seems that that the the
revised schedule said on the email that
went out was the
the scheduling of the exact session is
now
oh it said the uh the second that we
moved Thursday that Thursday didn't get
the Thursday just got moved back to
Wednesday
okay
okay don't worry about it because we
don't need Thursday we don't need a
second day we'll get everything done
in two hours
everything is next thing we'll be done
but we're here tomorrow
we're here tomorrow because we have a
next Wednesday the 19th and afterwards
we'll go to lunch what should I schedule
a lunch would everybody want to do a
lunch
okay
does that sound like a plan
next week we'll do it after Wednesday
we'll have a lunch